ladies and gentlemen i
have to start this episode by saying one
simple thing
joe rogan you were wrong you were wrong
i was right
you see my friends seven months ago it's
a little bit more than seven months ago
i was on the joe rogan podcast
and i told him joe we need a one world
government because the galactic
federation is not going to allow earth
to join
so long as we are not unified under one
governing authority and you know joe
said to me he said
i don't think there's a galactic
federation obviously i was
joking i thought the whole thing was
hilarious but now we have this kind of
funny story the former head of the
israeli space program said
aliens are real well he said ufos they
said galactic federation so he basically
said aliens are real
and they're waiting for us to kind of
calm down before revealing themselves
now
i know a lot of people are like tim this
is a click bait title it's not true well
hold on
there's a man named paul hellyer our
good friend luke rudkowski actually
knows him correct
yes i do and he was in an interview that
he did with me a couple years ago which
was
pretty eye opening to say the least
what's his title he is the former
canadian
defense minister he said aliens are real
not only that he said
aliens are real and they're not coming
to the earth because we keep fighting
each other
and they're denying us secret technology
and if we could stop
fighting we could have this so so so
basically we have
confirmation from a different government
different
authority figure different old guy
saying i don't give a
damn i'm going to be taking everything
on the table and letting the people know
what's going on and
uh yes paul heller and now this israeli
government official from the space
program coming out and
essentially saying the same thing it's
confirmation yeah
okay listen everybody calm down we're
having fun tonight
okay we're nearing the end of the year
the story comes out
everybody's rolling with it because it's
fun it's funny but let me ask you a
serious question
when a government official former
high-ranking official comes out and says
here's a thing
why would you choose to believe or
disbelieve them if
a former intelligence agent you know
came out and said or the head of an
intelligence agency
you know said donald trump was colluding
with the russians
we had what more than half this country
most people entertaining the possibility
at the very least
and many who still believe it right now
okay
i don't know if aliens are real if
they're coming here but you're the
challenges
who am i to question these two
individuals who have now said very
similar things
well it's not just them it's also harry
reid
well that's right harry reid just said
it didn't he bunch of old guys there's
also very interesting comments from
barack obama and bill clinton
that was a joke from of course what was
it or what
was it and we have to understand here
there is a lot of data there is a lot of
kind of circumstantial things coming
together that
all right picture that something could
be up it's gonna be a fun show cause we
got a ton of news to go through we got
this
this is a legitimate story from verified
like several different news outlets are
reporting the same thing this guy has
said this
that the ufos are here the galactic
federation we got to chill
and we got a bunch of news around this
especially quotes from obama
that was it was on jimmy kimmel we've
also got news about
microwave weapons potentially being used
in india and the havana syndrome which
is basically these people who were in
cuba like
diplomats started getting this weird
fatigue and like headaches and
memory loss and couldn't like fuzzy
vision
and they think it was that somebody was
using microwave weapons on them now
we're hearing
may actually be china who's doing it
this is crazy we've also got some other
really big stories we'll get to there
was a trump supporter that is house
bombed
and i don't know if there's a big story
or not but ian noticed this this is not
like reporting anywhere
what you notice that joe rogan's
episodes off youtube all gone yeah like
not all but most of them all the ones
that i could find the full episodes have
at least 4.4 million views so it looks
like he left a lot of his big shows up
a bunch of the joe rogan episodes are
gone
it feels kind of silly like you know
opening with a joke about joe but then
we actually have like something on his
channel and the only reason i would talk
about that is because it's the biggest
podcast in the world
but there actually is some news around
joe's show um
there's like a bunch of writing stuff
fans are upset you know i see people
making
you know comments about it but we'll get
into it because
you know i think a lot of people are
looking for celebrity gossip around this
stuff
but i do think it's it's it's it's
really important to talk about
you know where these uh these episodes
have gone why they're gone so anyway
ladies and gentlemen of course it's i'm
tim paul we're hanging out this tim
tim casserole podcast we got luke who
was just chiming in
you messed up my introduction i was
going to say help you're kidnapping me
you spelled help wrong i know i did it
on purpose and i did a little
uh temple drawing right here as well
just to highlight you spelled hell
it says i know i was going to act like
you're kidnapping me because you had me
on for like
three times it says kyle i know it was
pretty why but regardless of that
hi who are you dog whistling i
am the supreme allied commander behind
we are change.org
my favorite type of dog is a pit bull
pug and
an interesting fact about me is that
henry kissinger has personally insulted
me
to my face on many occasions that's very
cool so i like that
put that in your pipe and smoke it luke
you live a ridiculous life yes i do uh
ian's chilling of course
he's got a crystal ball with a tinfoil
hat on yeah and i truly believe when we
develop warp drive then the aliens will
be like okay now
that's star trek yep nah they're gonna
be like we're using you for cheap labor
so make our widgets there's an
interesting theory about nuclear weapons
that we're gonna be talking about in a
little bit
could be one of the reasons why aliens
are here according to some people who
theorize about it and don't forget patch
lids is producing i am i'm over the
corner i have an even special guest in
luke there was i looked down and there
was a little stink bug on my microphone
he's hanging out you can see him there
he's right he's on the bottom there oh
look there he is yeah anyway he's stink
bug season they're
trying to escape winter you're comparing
me to a stink bug no he's cooler no yeah
he's better
i like snake bugs they smell bad but
they're they're they're very clumsy
docile
yeah docile and clumsy and like it's
funny when they panic
and like it's like you're not escaping
you just like kind of frantically wonder
if that's like us with the aliens like
because it's like stink bugs we got a
lot to talk about with the aliens man
first
anyway all right let me actually pull up
i have this tweet but we'll pull up the
real news check this out this is from
jewishpress.com this is a news guard
certified website
i am doing this because the left is
going to be like tim pool conspiracy no
no no no snooze guarded news guard
92.5 out of 100 ladies and gentlemen
this
is almost as good as they come former
head of israel's space
program the aliens asked not to be
revealed humanity not
yet ready so this guy is professor
professor
mind you hey shed he served from 1981 to
2010 as the head of israel's security
space program
and over the years received the israeli
the israel's security award three times
twice for confidential technological
inventions so if he went nuts
and this possibility is always open it
had to have happened over the past
decade
and the reason we think the good
professor may have lost his marbles has
to do with an interview he gave
uh seven days ago i guess oh he gave
seven days
the shabbat edition of yeti off
okay italian israel's largest
circulation
for pay newspaper in which he says quote
the aliens have
asked not to announce that they are here
humanity is not ready yet
professor ashed told yeti off among
other things
here's this quote the ufos have asked
not to publish they are here
humanity is not yet ready well he kind
of just broke that promise
it's like hey dude don't let my you know
don't let my girlfriend know that i'm
going to be coming over yeah okay i'm
going to text her right now no no we're
doing aw come on man
trump was on the verge of revealing but
the aliens in the galactic federation
you see galactic federation
are saying wait let people calm down
first they don't want to start mass
hysteria they want to first make a sane
and understanding
they have been waiting for humanity to
evolve and reach a stage
where we will generally understand what
space and spaceships are
there's an agreement between the us
government and the aliens
they signed a contract with us to do
experiments here they too
are researching and trying to understand
the whole fabric of the universe and
they want us as helpers
there's an underground base in the
depths of mars where
where their representatives are and also
our american astronauts
if i had to come up with what i'm saying
today five years ago
i would have been hospitalized wherever
i've gone with this in academia they've
said the man has lost his mind
today they're already talking
differently i have nothing to lose
i've received my degrees and awards i am
respected in universities abroad where
the trend is also changing now
this is a man named paul hellyer luke
actually knows this guy
yeah former former defense minister i
went to a retreat with him at uh
at alex's well it's like one time for
some stream i don't want to confuse it
the next guy we're about to talk to is
paul heller that was the israel guy now
we got the canadian guy luke take it
away well the canadian guy
uh very powerful high level
guy that's one of the highest level of
government officials that came out and
came forward and said
aliens are real aliens do exist and he
pretty much was saying the same thing
that this israeli professor
that this head of the former israeli
space program is
saying security space program exactly
now if you look at some of the
revelations i think one of the most
interesting ones by
this professor is that allegedly these
aliens stopped
nuclear armageddon and this is a very
famous conspiracy theory
yes which is interesting because if you
look right after the manhattan project
right after the united states developed
and started testing nuclear weapons
there was a very big increase in rise in
supposed ufos unidentified flying
objects now hold on hold on
the u.s is doing secret military weapon
experiments
at the you know one of which is the
manhattan project so of course people
are seeing crazy things in the sky of
course
yes i'm not saying i'm just i'm just
saying what people are kind of
correlating together
paul hiller came out and said that there
are more
than just one species of aliens he
uh his latest interview he said that
there was four different species that
they've been visiting for thousands of
years
and that they want to quote give us
technology if we would stop
the wars and according to him because of
the atomic bomb they decided that humans
are a threat to the cosmos
wow and uh i mean if you look at some of
the kind of accusations here
you know let's just you know let's be
let's
hypothetically let's talk about them in
this kind of possibility here because
if we talk about aliens stopping nuclear
armageddon
when you go to the dmv you understand
that this is what the government
produces
it it shouldn't surprise you that there
hasn't been
a nuclear armor getting because these
same kind of people have nuclear weapons
so and there also have been many
instances where humanity has almost
blown
itself up there's many documented cases
of alarms going off that were
not really going off of nuclear
armageddon that were stopped no
you know that story the guy in the
submarine the russian guy and they got a
false alarm that
nuke was had it was fired from the u.s
and so they were like under protocol you
got to fire that nuke and retaliation
and he said no i won't do it yep and he
did not yeah what if he really did he
but the aliens stopped
it could be he he didn't follow basic
procedures and protocols like he was
asked to so he disobeyed a lawful order
which we need
more of to the world which uh which is
extremely commendable this man pretty
much saved the world from
nuclear armageddon some people you know
have different theories that this was
aliens
another thing that came out through this
latest revelations that
humans aren't ready that we have to be
quote sane and
understanding that was the exact quote
by this israeli professor who said
they want to first make us sane and
understanding
now if you look at current events
especially how people are beating the
crap out of each other because of their
political gangs
i think we have a little bit of uh
waiting to do until we all become sane
and understand
so so i one of the things i was joking
about was
that kovid what and and this is a joke
that the vaccine is because you ever see
war of the worlds the aliens come but
then they all die from like normal
illnesses that are
like we're immune to or like don't
bother us so i'm like there you go right
make everybody quarantined for a long
time get rid of as much of the pathogens
as possible then the galactic federation
comes i'm joking by the way i know
someone's gonna take it out of context
but mike cernovich tweeted this in ap on
april 27th he said
me they've kept us inside because they
want to reveal aliens
you a very serious person no me and then
he links to a story
from buzzfeed the pentagon has
officially released three videos showing
ufos
he just responded today with a jerusalem
post saying
oh and they mentioned the israeli
security chief but we do have
even more information just a few days
ago
leaked pentagon ufo report reveal shock
pick of
mystery silver cube over atlantic as
fears of aliens beneath
the seas check this out you can't really
see it's a tiny dot
look at that zoom in what is that that's
a crazy spaceship
well now the videos that we're talking
about that cernovich was talking about
were declassified
just seven months ago and they come from
2007
2017 they were released by the new york
times they were released by a larger
project of individuals coming together
outside of government
including with harry reid trying to get
as much information out there as
possible now
what's really interesting about the
government declassifying these videos
it's it's it's the same government
that's been lying
about these videos and about their
official task force
that is working towards discovering ufos
the united states for a very long time
has had a task force
the u.s military and the us government
has always been denying it
but now they're starting their own new
task force which is they just started a
couple
months ago which is really interesting
trump two months ago
also came out and said that he is going
to take a long and hard look
into aliens and then automatically he
started talking about the military
prowess of the united states which
maybe hypothetically the aliens said oh
we got to let joe biden win
what if what if what if the aliens what
if it's not china
that's you know the threat what if trump
is actually fighting against the aliens
he did start the space force which is
interesting to kind of theorize about it
and in the future
it's going to be the globe the the earth
globalists versus the galactivists
yes they're going to be like we live on
earth you know we're all from earth
we're humans
not these you know gazorpians now this i
think this
truly deserves to be discussed we can
laugh about it but i do think people
have their own kind of interpretations
it's important to note what people are
kind of
interpreting throughout some of this
kind of information dump that we're
seeing from some of these government
officials
and some of them are saying that this
could be fallen demons and angels this
is usually coming from the very
religious crowd
a lot of conspiracists are saying that
this is advanced
u.s technology to scare the public into
submission as documented and talked
about
through project bluebeam which theorizes
that a world of world of the world is
coming together
and that hypothetically the us
government is going to control people by
using fake aliens and watchmen
exactly you guys have you seen watchmen
the third group of people
some of it have you read watchmen
michael mouse got mad before we get in
that third group of people
are people who think there's ufos out
there and that might be ufo so so i
think it's important
i've read so we've seen this in
entertainment in hollywood just like we
saw in watchmen
uh what happened red different yes
so it's originally a graphic novel and
they made a movie out of it uh the movie
is very different in the in the graphic
novel
there's it's it's the cold war there's a
verge of nuclear apocalypse
so this uh the villain basically spoiler
alert
it's from the 80s i think so you know if
you haven't read it or seen the movie
he stages an alien invasion to create an
a unified enemy
so earth must come together and avert
nuclear apocalypse to defeat the aliens
and then you know there's like you know
stuff afterwards rorschach and he's got
his journal and then someone finds it
and stuff like that but
yeah stage an alien invasion because
then you can get everyone to come
together under a one world authority
but also think about intersectionality
right
the the the intersectionality uh inter
you know whatever you want to call it
the critical race theorist critical
gender theorists
they want to erase identity almost it's
weird though because they're very much
inflaming
i identified tensions but like if you
look at the surface of what they're
doing it's all about inclusivity and
diversity and
anyone can be anything they want and so
it's really
you know you can say that they're it's a
conspiracy but there really are people
who want to create a one
world government and this is this is not
this is not a conspiracy
right it's been since the end of world
war ii we had the league of nations and
we have
north atlantic uh you know we have nato
and
and now the u.n the goal of which is to
stop countries from attacking and
blowing each other up hitler wanted a
one-world government
he was in charge of i believe well so so
right now one of the big movements we've
seen from a lot of these
you know international interests has
been trade agreements under the under
the idea that creating a network of
trade lines will
will inhibit warfare and that's why
they're adamant about ramming through
ridiculous we don't care just make it
happen
and that's why we've seen other bigger
conspiracies about like economic
manipulation
like you know globalization but also uh
interesting that you're talking about
agreements since
another kind of uh revelation by this
professor is that allegedly there's a
contract
between the aliens and the humans why
would we need to do testing and the
question i have is who is enforcing this
contract
the church yeah they told us that god is
real but it's actually
aliens communicating with us you ever
play assassin's creed
no like the i don't know i don't know
where it has this creed has happened a
little bit of it but the original was
basically that like aliens created like
seated earth
and then there's like what what they
what they're actually finding is ancient
technology
so it's like a long-standing conspiracy
or science fiction idea
that you know what we view as religious
or or magical was actually just ancient
times what if
us swearing allegiance to god is is
giving is swearing allegiance to an
alien force
and that tesla was so tapped into the
divine that he was getting the
information and he built these
lightweight dronecraft check this out
and then so there's he built these
lightweight aluminum craft that can be
controlled from the ground wireless
electricity
but they can also be controlled from the
aliens well that's how they're
using us to create things that they can
slow down you got to slow down
never yeah no no no you just met you
just you just said like three different
things that have nothing to do with what
we're talking about are you like me now
i i did meet a tesla secret society in
serbia that believed that tesla was
literally communicating without her
being so there are individuals right i
relieve some of this stuff but to say
that people praying to god are praying
aliens
and then all of a sudden but that's okay
we can stop what if that's the compact
okay the contract we can then start
talking about something different
right why is it that the kings and
queens of all these different countries
were kings and queens
you know why divine providence yeah god
told the divine right of law yes
it was it was it was there right by god
so what if it was actually aliens saying
we want you to be in charge dude i'm
wondering
there's a lot of things we could uh you
know theorize about we could say that if
you do dmt you see the aliens but i
think
there's two clear things here that are
undeniable
uh one is that we're not ready we're
divided we're fighting each other over
absolute nonsense
i think that's partly true and the
second thing is what was the second
thing
um is that we need more information
there's so much lack of information that
people are just making stuff up to fill
in the holes and we don't need to
agree i think i think when we look at
the
latest revelations by harry reid who
came out and said the government is
lying the government is hiding
information from this i think that's
credible he said we had
alien spacecraft or something like that
yes i think i think that's that's
credible
we need more information we need more
transparency we need more accountability
and because we don't
blood we have all these theories we
don't have to concentrate on the series
we should all concentrate
on getting more accountability from our
government okay tell us what's going on
okay okay mr anarchist okay if there was
a grand conspiracy covering up all these
aliens that effective they could easily
stage any kind of conspiracy to unify
the planet against aliens
the people will freak out and go nuts if
an alien mothership appears
and we're powerless to do anything
against it and that could disrupt the
economy and result in billions dying
because supply chains break everything
like that
so maybe mike said which was right i
don't know if he was being serious
but they're keeping us inside they're
breaking the supply chains now to
cushion it
so when the aliens come out the shock
can only go so far
i doubt they're that organized that's
smart have you seen that
that technology where coca-cola was
beaming advertisements into the sky
and there were these giant like
coca-cola advertisements and then the
countries were like we're gonna make it
illegal because it's air
light pollution what if they do that
with an alien ship like
war of the worlds orson welles as an
entertainment thing but people really
believe it's a real
alien craft and go crazy could be
because if you look at the latest us
military technology
it is far older than what we know it to
be so there are many
military advancements there are many
technological advancements that are kept
away from the general public
so there could be a you know space beam
or whatever kind of crazy weapons out
there that we still
don't know because it's still classified
just like many of the airplanes that
you know we see in movies but existed
for a very long
time for military use but we never knew
they even existed what if i told you
that all of this was already admitted to
by previous
united states presidents you're talking
about barack obama barack obama said
he said the aliens won't let it happen
you will reveal all of their secrets
they exercise strict control over us let
me let me reenact exactly what obama
said
he was having a very very serious and
important conversation with one of our
great american thought leaders
jimmy kimmel yes and he said the aliens
won't let it happen
you have you you you you will reveal all
their secrets they have strict
can they exercise strict control over us
right those bombs he was like
you will reveal the secrets i'm kidding
it was a gag
bit he did say it but you take the quote
out of context and yes
people think it's real so i actually
have this is funny this is a ufo website
where they're like obama said the aliens
won't let it happen
they exercise strict control and he's
laughing and then jimmy kimmel says
now there's going to be people who
analyze everything you say and how you
looked when you said it
because it was a joke that's true and
bill clinton made a similar comment as
well
and again some of these things are
legitimate legitimately jokes but there
are some serious implications
just like with china china literally
built the largest
radio dish and telescope so they could
try to communicate
with aliens you look up well hold on
yeah and then if it's true the aliens
are here why would they build it
maybe they're not talking to the chinese
maybe the chinese know something that we
don't know about but they're spending a
tremendous amount of money they're
saying
for aliens i don't know maybe they don't
like how the
you know the chinese are doing gene
splicing right now to build super
soldiers which
maybe they're allegedly happening uh
from an article that
just was released a couple days ago who
knows i have no idea no one really knows
until we get more answers from the
government that clearly is
lying about it and uh we need more i
don't know man
have you had did you listen to the 9 a.m
cnn tapes from project veritas
no so uh you heard about this right ian
lydia no yeah i think so
yeah project veritas has recorded the
9am phone calls from cnn
yeah this this is relevant trust me what
you learn
is that there is no grand conspiracy
just bumbling morons yep
you get the president of cnn jeff sucker
being like so um today i think man you
know tucker carlson's a racist and uh
maybe that's we should talk about that
and they're like i really agree you know
he's very racist
and you'd think hearing this call it's
just like her being like
all right everyone listen today we're
gonna frame tucker carlson we're gonna
accuse him of no it was
he literally believes it it's just a
bunch of morons talking about their dumb
[ __ ] stuff
well they're supporting their special
interests at the end of the day and they
make sure that they never bite the hand
that feeds them now it might not be such
a sophisticated complex
thing like we see in major think tanks
that usually provide all the talking
points but
we do see it as a pretty effective
regurgitating machine
that just does what it's told and maybe
there's no orders top down but maybe
they just have the individuals that
believe
in what they believe in that are on the
same page you know you want to know why
i'll be honest with you i don't think
aliens
come here is that maybe they do but it's
like
i was watching this video about life and
it was really really interesting
perspective they said
think about the evolutionary distance
between a human being
and an ant it's like a billion years or
something like that but
still infinitely closer in
you know uh like how we function and
thrive and the fuels we use and the air
and things like that than an alien race
on a planet that would say
all water or you know a different you
know chemical composition
but more importantly they said think
about the difference between a human and
a dog
humans and dogs actually communicate
very well
for inter-species relationship dogs can
learn words in english can especially
really smart ones like border collies
but you can never explain to a dog what
a suit what a highway is
you you can't explain to a dog what an
international trade route is
you can explain to the dog loud noise
scary car hurt
very simple things now think about an
advanced species
that is able to travel you know beyond
the speed of light or interdimensionally
or whatever
why would they try and communicate with
something infinitely separated from us
that's why you gotta take mushrooms my
buddy my buddy's dog accidentally got
into a bag of his mushrooms
it got really smart it realized it was a
dog and it would get it would like
really get angry at us when we didn't
treat it you don't know what it knew
well you can't read it okay let's stop
talking about mushroom dogs here but i
just i i
disagree with you and i do believe that
there are aliens i think that
why i think especially from the video
footage we saw that was released
of that unidentified flying object that
was defying the laws of physics defying
them
when it comes to this israeli professor
when it comes to paul heller
sitting down with them looking them in
the eyes these are old individuals who
have nothing to lose
who just i think we're at the highest
elements of government
that are now on their death bed trying
to get as much information out there to
to you can't afford to listen i mean you
know i i agree what i'm saying is when
you're
that age they got nothing over you
exactly what are they going to threaten
you with exactly so
i think that adds an extra layer of
credibility to some of their allegations
this israeli professor said this and i
think i'm going to i'm just going to
quote him directly because i think this
is important
he said quote if i had come up with what
i'm saying today five years ago i would
have been hospitalized
whenever i've gone with this in academia
they said
the man has lost his mind today they're
already talking differently i have
nothing to lose i received my degrees
and awards i am respected in
universities abroad
where the trend is also changing i'm
happy this trend is changing it needs to
change a little bit more
it's fun to joke about but we need more
information we need more accountability
what the hell is the government hiding
from us because they have a lot that
don't know
weapons let me let me let me let me tell
you something very very simple right
how many planets exist that have the
identical chemical composition to earth
a lot identical oh identification
probably
zero similar that we know about in the
valley that we know
and based on calculations they're i
think it's fair to say a lot but what is
a lot relative to
the you know 40 transactions 10 000 or
something
maybe right now think about this would
life
so there's there's two ideas here alien
life could look like who knows what
it could be a gigantic pulsating mass
with like a thousand little tentacle
arms
it wouldn't necessarily look like a
human or have arms or legs
think about a dolphin right really smart
no hands
and underwater they can't create fire to
manipulate elements to create
any kind to break things things down and
create circuits and build
dolphins never gonna build a rocket ship
it's not possible so you have to think
about
there's actually an argument for why
aliens would probably
if they did exist like our planet the
chemical composition allows us to
manipulate elements to create computers
and and rockets and things like that
and other kind of technology that you
can't do in a water or atmosphere that
maybe would ignite instantly
so that means there may be a bunch of
aliens really smart ones on a bunch of
other planets
that can't do anything can ever leave or
maybe their technology is
just they can only get to a certain
level but then if you look at where
we're at
it's possible because we have rocketry
that there will be another you know
alien
species that came from very similar
conditions where they had
uh the right amount of oxygen in the
atmosphere so they could create fire
allowing them to separate elements out
and then do electrolysis and things like
that
however what if we are actually the
aliens yeah trapped in the oxygen
atmosphere
and the other super advanced aliens live
in this crazy planet
where they can better access and
manipulate all the different elements
and they look at us like dolphins who
are trapped forever you can never
hear panspermia that the universe is
seeded
um basically by life that's the star
trek lore and that like
a fungal spores which can exist in deep
space and survive were sent throughout
the universe for whatever reason and
landed in our oceans and then
evolved over time started to eat other
fungus and became animal and that's kind
of
uh we're instead of evolutions we're
actually adaptations of that life form
for this environment it's like
prometheus so you're saying the earth is
not flat
yes that's basically where i was going
it's a concave bowl right is that is
that the actual theory with a
turtle on it no no no no they they say
that when the people when people say the
earth is flat it's actually got a
a ridge around it of ice so it's it's
the firmament it's a bowl
it's a bowl and so it collects the
little space dust and the little fungus
comes and rains down and i like that
you know what i love about flat earth do
you know how they think gravity works
no they they think you got a stink bug
on your mic
they think that the uh the flat earth is
exponentially speeding up moving upward
oh it's just sucking us down
and that mathematically the speed will
never stop you know tell me that
one more time i was looking at the bug
they believe that that the earth is
exponentially moving faster in an upward
direction
oh that's pinning us down yeah we could
also be following it
and the entire universe that we perceive
could be falling at the same speed
and we wouldn't know because it was all
relative to that's a better way to put
it we're upside down falling and we're
standing on it just like
anyway so i think what's happened is
octopi
humans you know our brain stem creature
that is inside this saltwater sac
is like an alien well the brain stem is
salt water so i think that
we're all kind of alien life forms that
were seeded to earth but these craft
that are flying around
are like tesla lightweight aluminum
craft that the government co-opted from
his laboratory and is
secretly lying to us and telling us that
it's aliens throw us off the trail
but i could make up a million one things
you know what i mean we could keep going
all night here right right right so
let's do this let's do this
let me tell you what i think is really
going on there's a lot of people
watching right now
i know you're staring into that camera
you're i'm sorry i'm starting the camera
you're looking at your computer screen
and you see what a humble tim pool
looking in the eyes
and you're saying please tim i want
aliens to be real please
just tell me they're real and i'll say
no sorry
sorry to burst your bubble luke aliens
are not real
military technology could be military
hold on
military technology because i'm i'm
gonna i'm gonna blow your minds
we got another story here check this out
havana syndrome likely caused by pulsed
microwave energy
government study fines exclusive uh
report on neurological symptoms of us
diplomats in china cuba
does not address what whether directed
energy was delivered intentionally by a
weapon
but it's called havana syndrome people
were getting crazy brain debilitating
effects
they were hearing a weird humming sound
and it was likely a
newly developed weapon that we don't
know about and it could have been rolled
out by the chinese or the russians which
have pretty good ties with
cuba now the cubans are saying that this
was just a generator obviously the
weapons the other diplomats are saying
it's something else but we do know
microwave weapons have existed for a
very long time
it was what deployed in iraq yeah
what's it called gulf war what's the
name of it i forgot the exact same name
of it
the one the one in a row we might have
to look that up the the weapon they used
in iraq makes you feel like you're on
fire
burns your body from the inside and a
similar weapon is reported to be used in
the contested
territory between china and india right
now
chinese and indian troops have literally
killed themselves in a dispute
over a slot of land which both of the
countries are recognizing as theirs
they have put their troops on the border
and the one of the conditions that they
had they made they actually made a
treaty is that the soldiers that would
be on the border wouldn't be armed
with rifles or guns or or any actual
deadly weapons like machine guns but the
chinese allegedly according to the
indians rolled
out a microwave weapon and started
microwaving a bunch of indian troops
which forced them to leave and now the
chinese took their territory
in this contested area it is called it
is raytheon's
active denial system a non-lethal
directed energy
weapon developed by the u.s military
designed for area denial perimeter
security and crowd control
informally the weapon is also called the
heat ray since it works by heating the
surface of targets
such as the skin of targeted of targeted
human beings raytheon had marketed a
reduced ranged version of this tech
the ads was deployed in 2010 with the us
military in the afghanistan war
but was withdrawn without seeing combat
on august 20 2010 the la sheriff's
department announced its intent to use
the tech to control
incarcerated people in the pitches
detention center in la
stating the intent to use it in an
operational evaluation situation such as
breaking up prisoner fights
as of 2014 the ads was only was only a
vehicle-mounted weapon
though u.s marines and police were both
working on portable versions
ads was developed under the sponsorship
of the us
the dod non-lethal weapons program with
the air force research laboratory as the
lead
lead agency there are reports that
russia and china
are developing their own versions of the
active denial system but
let's talk about a kind of weapon that
doesn't heat your skin but goes into
your brain
and causes permanent vision damage it
causes
what is it called vertigo you lose your
balance you feel crazy
and just general malaise check this out
nbc news reports
the mysterious neurological symptoms
experienced by american diplomats in
china and cuba
are consistent with the effects of
directed microwave energy
according to a long-awaited report by
the national academies of sciences
that cites medical evidence to support
the long-held conviction
of american intelligence officials the
report obtained friday by nbc news
does not conclude the directed energy
directed energy was delivered
intentionally
by a weapon as some u.s officials have
long believed but it raises that
disturbing possibility
5g i'm kidding i'm kidding
6g have you guys seen that show on
amazon truth seekers
truth seekers yeah so uh it's uh it's
like um
this guy works for a phone company he's
installing 5g and then i'm gonna
i don't want to spoil the show i'm gonna
i'm gonna spoil them a little tease but
uh
eventually like they're where they're
working on it and then the guy who who
runs the cell phone company goes
we have to deploy what does he call it
eight was it eight gt yeah and they're
like what do you mean hey we're on five
and he goes we've got it all ready we're
just holding on to it
and that's that that that's funny too is
in terms of conspiracies
because i'd be willing to believe i
remember when ford gtech was coming out
cell phone companies were holding back
because they were like people are still
paying for 3g so we're gonna do it real
slow to make as
much money as possible before rolling
out the better tech
i digress we now have news reports
you know what's crazy about the havana
syndrome thing is that when it was first
reported
it was it was it was people in cuba u.s
diplomats saying they were getting
headaches
they were getting becoming light
sensitive they couldn't look at light
they'd wear glasses special glasses
they were feeling fatigued they were
getting you know dizzy
and everybody said oh it's probably just
hysteria
that's what we heard from so many
reporters many national security
reporters they said
this is not real it's a placebo effect
mass hysteria from people who report
something and then someone else gets
scared and then thinks they're
experiencing and then everyone just
starts to claim they have these symptoms
now it's real now we have a report
saying no it's real and we don't know
who's doing it
but when we talk about aliens and stuff
like that i think it is
infinitely well maybe i should say
infinitely but astronomical odds
more likely you know or less like it's
astronomical that it's aliens
it's extremely extremely likely that
once again as we've already seen
throughout generation or generation and
hundreds and thousands of years
government making new weapons and
keeping them a secret or corporations
absolutely absolutely well both could be
true and now corporations in the
military-industrial complex are making
new weapons new technologies and
just new ideas and concepts that our
mind hasn't even conceived
the possibility of even becoming a
reality so i think
i mean especially if you look at the
history of the us military and the roll
out of their devices of their weapons of
their ships
of their aircraft it's always beyond the
scope of what humans could imagine
the germans had a very impressive you
know uh space program and also
the bell yes is that real um
we were playing okay so we're playing
this game called conspiracy theory was
it is it called conspiracy theory the
game is called conspiracy
conspiracy could be wrong it's a trivia
game and i'm really offended because
some of their questions were wrong and i
was right and i didn't get
the points for it anyway but uh
yeah no it was okay they said that the
hand sign associated with the illuminati
was the okay hand sign so weird
that's not true definitely it's the
devil horns anyway anyway
they mentioned one of the questions was
the the nazis had something called the
bell
i guess what was that it was like
anti-grav or something
um they were working conspiracy the
nazis were working on some high advanced
level stuff they were working on
either the nuclear weapon they were
working on uh you know they also made a
lot of advancements when it came to
airplanes and propulsion that the world
has never seen before and when we look
at
rocketry yeah when we look at something
like the manhattan project we have to
understand there was a lot
of nazis also a part of that program
with
a project paper clip where the united
states military literally ran through
germany as much as they could and got as
many
people in the german scientific
community and brought them back
to the united states before the war was
over none of them asylum
was after after the war but this program
yeah they got asylum and they never
this is any retribution any any crimes
for for the horrible things that they
did who was who was the guy who made
rockets
there's a lot of yeah i know there's a
dude
yeah yeah yeah like the main guy had
that famous quote where he said
it performed perfectly just landed on
the wrong planet because he was actually
dreaming of going to the start i'm gonna
look it up check it out
the manhattan project do you know what
the u.s invented the manhattan project
it's a nuclear weapon which count which
one the first one
what was the first one what kind of bomb
was it um not hydrogen
it was it was the atomic bomb yeah but
it was a specific kind of atomic bomb
yeah
it's called the gravity bomb what that
means did you drop it yep
what happened after the united states
went to germany and snatch up all them
rocket scientists
they started putting the warheads on top
of rockets and then we got the
intercontinental ballistic missile
werner von braun
yes bernier von braun at the v2 rocket
was credited so
man that's how you headed the department
we ended up with some crazy stuff when
we took the the nazi scientists they
came to the united states
and then we took our understanding of
all these crazy opens you know the nazis
were building like massive artillery
right
to fire like ridiculously huge shells
they had a very in like
different way of thinking about weapons
putting you know rocket trains stuff
like that for us it was like
let's create a massive explosion and
just wipe everything out
then we go over there after that we're
like hey those things you built that
went really far
can we put our thing on it so that it
blows up and goes really far at the same
time
yeah do you know what a mirv is a
multiple independently
targeting re-entry vehicle it's an
intercontinental ballistic missile can
carry eight to twelve warheads
it is about my understanding is about 1
000 times more powerful than the bombs
dropped on japan in world war
ii it flies into the stratosphere breaks
open and drops
eight to twelve warheads that is the
incendi people don't realize how far we
went with nuclear weapons
we went nuts our bomba that thing
it was insane and how many biggest tests
and how many times we actually launched
nuclear weapons during testing
facilities i mean we're talking about in
the thousands
thousands of times the united states
government released nuclear bombs and
blew them up
some of the worst some of the worst
scientists that committed
the most awful human experiments in nazi
germany
japan were brought back to the united
states as part of this project
and when when it comes to the nuclear
weapon there's many political scholars
that believe
the only reason the united states
dropped the nuclear weapon was to show a
sign of strength against
russia the ussr at the time to show them
that they mean business because at the
time the ussr was also grabbing as many
scientists as they could and rushing
towards berlin
to make sure that they could get as much
control of that area as they could
and of course when we look at history
when we look at the history of the heart
attack gun something that's not
widely talked about but the cia the
central intelligence agency had a gun
all the way back in the 70s that was
real that's not cool
lydia that's not cool at all knowing
that the cia could literally
shoot you look at the dog and forced you
to have a heart attack or
force you to get very serious cancer and
this was all the way back
in the 70s that was revealed through
major important senate commission
hearings
that revealed a lot of this information
and the astronomical power
that the intelligence agencies have in
our society they use the heart attack
gun we have the story this is from we
are the mighty.com
news guard certified i'm doing that
because we are in
this year's conspiracy check this out
spurred by the publication of seymour
hirsch's article in the new york times
in december 1974 the u.s congress
decided to look into just what his
internal and external intelligence
agencies were doing in the name of the
american people
they found among other things a gun that
caused heart attacks
a weapon that had been used against the
u.s political enemies and beyond
yeah and that was 50 years ago so now
imagine what they have
right now that's why i think that they
don't have microwave electronic weapons
you're fooling yourself
and uh you know you're saying the thing
about the aliens but both could be true
the us could be building up their
military might and their military
technology along with the chinese and
the russians and all of them
and aliens could also exist at the same
time there could be some training
programs
i'm just saying they're not exclusive to
each other that's what i'm saying one of
the stories i was reading about
so you saw these stories where they're
like ufo videos got released right
yeah the ufos are captured by military
jets
right so once they get released it's
like air force pilots are flying
the funniest thing about some of these
stories i was reading one and it was
like we were about a hundred miles away
from the advanced you know uh
intel intelligence and technology
research center for the us navy
and then we saw these strange vehicles
and i'm like so weird yes
unrelated tell me more about where you
were and why you were there
could be again anything's possible we
don't know we need more information from
the government i think that's true and i
think everyone could agree
about that but when it comes to gain of
function research when it comes to heart
attack guns when it comes to microwave
weapons
um can we admit that this is getting a
little bit out of hand that this is a
little bit crazy especially with
the we need the aliens especially with
the latest allegations
from the united states accusing china of
literally
gene splicing and manipulating human
beings to be super soldiers dude it's
completely out of hand yes i mean what
the
what well this is an accusation from an
anonymous u.s intel source which should
be questioned
to the highest extent but it wouldn't
surprise me if china or even the united
states
at this point was doing something to
create super soldiers probably corporate
the corporate power is really getting
out of here this
is nuts yes check this story out
china conducting biological tests to
create super soldiers
us spy chief says that's recent
intelligence director john ratcliffe
claims
human testing aims to develop super
soldiers with biologically enhanced
capabilities
yeah two days ago the article came from
an anonymous source now i guess he's
kind of a guardian with it
the guardian this is you want to play
look look look
i keep saying news guard certified i say
it because we're talking about aliens
and
space weapons heart attacks and i know
someone from media matters is sitting
there going like ooh they're writing it
all down
it's the guardian the guardian says that
china's
john ratcliffe is saying this check us
out writing in the wall street journal
ratcliffe said quote the intelligence is
clear
beijing intends to dominate the us and
the rest of the planet economically
militarily and technologically many of
china's major public initiatives and
prominent companies
offer only a layer of camouflage to the
activities of the chinese communist
party
ratcliffe said china had gone to
extraordinary lengths to achieve its
goal
quote u.s intelligence shows that china
has been conducting
has even conducted human testing on
members of the people's liberation army
in hope of developing soldiers with
biologically enhanced capabilities
there are no ethical boundaries to
beijing's pursuit of power
remember just the it was a year ago we
learned that a rogue scientist was
genetically altering babies
and they arrested him and he did
actually yeah yeah check this out
he's probably working for the us about a
year ago no no no i
got i got a different thought chinese
scientists who edited babies genes
jailed for three years
two theories one they saw what he was
doing and they said
i want your research we want to
weaponize it two
he was a scientist who was familiar with
their research and went rogue and was
using it and they were like
stop don't let don't let people find out
what you're
drawing too much attention to what we're
doing with these programs if this
doesn't show you that
china is preparing for war i don't know
what other sign you need to see
it's right there on the wall i mean when
you look at their
the you know all the money that they're
spending literally trying to communicate
with aliens
building up their entire naval fleet
building up
military man-made islands microwaving
soldiers on the border of
india and stealing us military
technology that they've been getting
from israel that's another thing that if
i don't know if you want to look up
lydia but israel many times has
given out intelligence secrets from the
united states and sold it
to china there was even an israeli
defense minister that had to resign
in a major controversy because china was
able to get their hands on advanced usa
listen listen we have the story about
india and china the microwave weapons so
india is disputing the claim that china
routed their troops with microwave
blaster
i i don't i don't know how to believe
but i kind of believed the microwave
initial reports was that indians felt
like they were being
lit up in fire from the inside and then
they had to run away because the pain
was excruciating
let's talk about what's going on with
these super soldiers like what exactly
are they doing what
cause listen listen we got all this
sci-fi with all these movies you got
things like uh
have you watched the boys no have you
seen the boys yeah
awesome show and it's basically spoiler
alert for those that haven't seen the
second season
are having if look it's it's it's been
out for a while now so you know it's
you've nothing no blame but yourself you
haven't watched it homeland
nazi scientists escaped to the us and
they developed a super soldier serum
that gives people superpowers but mostly
only works in babies it's most stable in
babies
and they're trying to figure out how to
get it into people and they've kind of
figured it out
so in this show people can fly and they
can shoot laser beams and they heal and
they're invulnerable
clearly gene editing can't do that but
what if they made someone have the
maximum jump height
you've heard of the acoustic levitation
well we have to understand right you
can't a human's not going to
know if you can vibrate liquid and make
it meditate then why can't parents have
enough money they could take
the sperm from the guy the egg from the
mom and they could go to a laboratory
that literally
picks out the best combination where you
could select the height
right the genetic disposition of your of
your of your child so it's already
happening so to
think that this is not happening on a
military level where
they're taking the best elite special
forces green beret guys and taking their
dna
and duplicating it to match with the
best of the best when it comes to
fighting and meaning and killing other
people
you'd be killing you'd be kidding
yourself there's been many movies about
this that were fictional
where the guy finally gets some
consciousness this super soldier that's
created finally starts fighting back
against the empire and takes them down
because they made him too strong
and we could hope for that but life is
not a movie
and this is absolutely terrifying that
there's super soldiers out there
that have been genetically put together
you want to know why that could be
to be assassins you wanna know that's a
very serious problem yeah obviously
okay first of all what they're going to
be doing is likely programming
individuals
this is this is this is the guardian
john ratcliffe like this is being
reported okay
they can't just take a random person
who's loyal to the people's liberation
army and say we're gonna you know inject
you with the serum it's gonna change
your dna or something
they're gene editing babies and probably
people to a certain degree like
adults but babies is the easiest way to
do it they'll grow into it they're
probably then raising these kids in
special conditions and training them to
be super soldiers now
here's the problem with genetic
engineering if that
escapes into the human gene pool and you
don't know what those genes will do in
the long run
you could taint the entire human gene
pool with some failing genome
and then in 50 to 100 years it's this
this genes become widespread in most
populations
and then everyone gets a debilitating
disease and dies it's coronavirus
no i'm not talking about viruses i'm
talking about are they working on a this
is not a virus
you can use viruses you're you're
totally derailing off of everything i'm
talking about no i'm not
questioning if that's a bible no they
use the genetic program gene editing is
e coli they don't use coronavirus for
this
what i'm saying is that when we
genetically engineer crops yeah you can
use viruses to edit genes
yes e coli not coronavirus you don't
know that
i literally i'm talking what yes they do
gene editing by using e coli to
manipulate uh the the
genetic structure or something like that
i don't know there was a big green tea
as a bacteria but you brought
up you brought up a very good point
because again people are playing
uh you know like they're like they're
gods they're essentially
coming up with these powers that they're
going to be using for the quote greater
good because if you're in china the
greater good is to create super soldiers
to fight the bad americans
and the americans are being told the
same thing we need to create probably
super soldiers i wouldn't
i wouldn't doubt that this project is
being done on some kind of
offshoot contractor that doesn't face
any liability or
accountability like a government agency
and when we look at the defense
department
they are becoming more and more
dependent on doing a lot of their
experiments
and a lot of their very borderline
unethical activities
through private companies and third
parties that again
you can't get any records of what
they're actually doing
so here's what i'm saying we've we've
seen select
gene editing in many different crops and
then there's been accusations for a long
time that these companies
will drive up to a farm and chuck seeds
into the field
so that the gene mixes with all of their
crops and then they can copyright it
or they they they have cycle right
monsanto has intellectual property
ownership over the genome
then they'll they sow the seeds
everywhere so that every plant in these
farms
you know interbreeds with them and then
they come back later take a sample and
say aha you're using our proprietary
technology you owe us money
this eventually destroys the existence
of the original
crop so i was reading something i don't
know
you have to uh if those listening fetch
me on this one i was reading there used
to be like you know
hundreds of different kinds of apples
and now there's only like a small
handful of varieties there's a bunch of
different kinds of potatoes and now we
only have a small
you know amount of varieties because we
consume and deplete one
and then favor another and replace it so
like you'll go and you'll see like a
certain potato you'll eat it and say
well this one's better and you'll plant
that one instead
if they're editing human beings and then
let's say in 20 years they abandon the
program
and now these edited human beings are
just wandering around and like i don't
know and i start having families and
kids
how long until those edited genes exist
across the world especially if they're
like enticing humans like faster more
attractive then their genes are going to
spread faster
naturally but what if they're also bred
to be more vicious
and not to have that empath empathetic
response because they're supposed to be
killing machines
what if the goal is to create a super
soldier which means they can't hesitate
when killing for any reason
and then you get these people start
having kids and also you got about uh uh
just
generations of social i think it's gonna
happen i mean i just think it's like
the fallout future of you got the
mutants and you have the cyborgs and
like some people have like genetic
legs you're genetically altered to run
faster some people have cybernetic
implants to let them run faster
some people have genetic eye and their
eyes are genetically so they can see ten
times further some people have
cybernetic
you know contact lenses so they can see
ten times further while
trillions of dollars is being spent on
this madness
there's still people in flint who can't
get clean drinking water
i mean for foreign are you kidding me
and i think
you know this is important to talk about
and to kind of
theorize because this is a reality and
there is a big possibility that these
genetically modified super soldiers
already exist
genetic modification already happens to
our food and there's this famous quote
by albert einstein that said
world war iv would be fought with sticks
and stones
and to me uh sorry world war five would
be fought with sticks and stones i don't
know what world war ii
let me read the quote let me read the
question i do not know with what weapons
world war three will be fought
but world war iv will be bought fought
with sticks and stones
i love that guy and i think that's
absolutely true with the scale
of military advancement and technology
that we have come to
that already is very difficult for human
beings to to
to understand and to deal with i mean
human beings already are dealing
with a massive psychological negative
effect because of
the internet there's no denying the
psychological
downtroddeness of humanity mainly
because of these little dopamine devices
that have been gamified
by special interests that literally run
our entire lives now so
uh i can tell you that world war four
will not be fought with sticks and
stones
i can tell you that we are in it right
now and it is fifth generation warfare
yeah it is information and propaganda
control of opinions so this is something
i've been saying for quite some time and
i didn't make it up there's actually
several
research papers published on the matter
what is the goal of war and we've talked
about this right
you want to assert control over a group
of people gain access to resources or
just you know have them work on your
behalf for some reason
or maybe even prevent a potential
conflict in the past the easiest way to
get it done
was it when when all else fails you
point a gun at them and say do it or
else
and you you you suppress them and you
get rid of the ruling class you get rid
of the officers the professors any
professionals in the society they're
just
gone but you come in with force you come
in with guns yeah just like my people
saw
world war ii yeah with world war ii with
germany and of course the ussr they took
over
took anyone influential and they just
you know mandated everything to be done
we are in the information age there's no
reason to do any of that when you can
convince people to bow for you to give
up
to destroy their own economies and look
at what's happening in the us right now
if i had to make a bet if someone came
to me and said would you be willing to
place a substantial wager on the us
is under attack through propaganda and
influence campaign
so the country destroys itself i would
say yes i believe yeah it's weird to
think
of it as an attack that's i think the
dissonance that people are facing
you know because the scary aspect of
this is when you see
the amount of control that china has on
hollywood
yup that should absolutely terrify you
when you see i think there was even a
recent movie
that was just totally banned in china
because of one little small phrase and
then that movie is going to lose out on
a ton of revenue
that a whole bunch of hollywood
executives that literally are compared
to satanists
that's what hollywood executives are
compared to because they would sell
their soul
or just shaking at the boots because of
how much money and how much profit they
could be getting
and when you look at that just one small
example of our everyday lives
it should terrify you oh yeah we had the
nba
we had the famous you know basketball
players coming out and saying leave
china alone we had the hearthstone
uh game players at free hong kong we
have
in this country a large group of
powerful and influential people who have
already sworn capitalistic
allegiance to the chinese communist
party no joke no exaggeration
yeah well this is why also the central
intelligence agency from its inception
always swooned hollywood producers
actors to be a part of its official
psychological programs and its official
agency since of course
the cia also has a very big involvement
in hollywood and they know
culture movies music everything that we
do when we
fifth generational warfare when we don't
try to think and we just try to enjoy
ourselves as being used and weaponized
in a way for a particular outcome that
we don't even
know about whether it's subliminal
messaging or just outright propaganda or
disinformation or psychological warfare
we have to understand we're in the
middle of it right now there's a major
war happening
there's a lot of lives being lost
there's a lot of people
killing themselves when they don't need
to be killing themselves there's a lot
of people
driven into making mistakes with their
lives because they see rich and famous
people doing it
and they're like i could do that too i
should take this
pill or this narcotic or i should be a
degenerate
this way as well the culture and how
it's being usurped so people become
their own worst enemies is something to
really highlight and to look at because
if you look at
what's been coming out in the tv shows
in the movies
in the mainstream media it's all against
families it's all
against breaking people apart making
sure you fight each other making sure
you hate each other on the micro
difference that you could even find in a
human being so
that's where we're at right now yes we
have that story uh well i'll just pull
up the article we had the story
i covered this earlier in the morning
macomb county man says he was targeted
with
explosives due to his politics two
mortars
a common weapon used by antifa was
thrown thrown into his house by somebody
drove by got out chucked him into his
house
exploded get a big old trump sign now we
don't know if this is politically
motivated
but it's an example of social media
breeding this tribalistic hatred
but here's here's what i don't
understand then if the cia
is as good as the as good as they are
what they do why are they allowing it
why are why why would they allow this
country to eviscerate itself
that's a very good question because uh
it it it
does essentially mean people are
shooting themselves in the foot but
when we look at the history of the cia
they have a long history of doing a lot
of
immoral illegal things that haven't been
done ethically but all but here's my
question are they doing i don't know
that they make it for the country to
strengthen the country or what
now there's a good analogy here to
really kind of consider
and to think about if you were a farm
owner and you had a whole bunch of wild
animals all over the place
would it be better for you to subjugate
them to control them to lock them up in
cages and to do what you want them to do
or would you want a farm to be
free roaming and running around and i
think there's an element of this that we
do have to understand that there are
individuals
that do want to subjugate individuals to
benefit off of them and i think
that is true now the motives of the cia
we don't know we just know their history
which is
riddled in a lot of seedy
illegal illicit activities heart attack
guns who in their right mind creates a
heart attack gun
and that's verified yeah from the
beginning like
like secretly killing the king you know
poisoning them or doing it so that you
don't have to be involved
it's just then it's the way when you
make excuses for the greater good
you're essentially becoming a large
problem
for everyone but you're you're
convincing yourself that you're doing it
for
the you know righteous causes and when
you have a limited power that's
unchecked unlimited money
that they just get blanket you know sent
to them no matter what
that that drives a person insane and
when we look at the cia when we look at
presidents that try to curtail their
power
what has happened kennedy kennedy
notably spoke out against the cia
trump as well so oh yeah but but trump
also kind of flip-flopped on that but
but
there were times where he went at them
pretty hard pretty significantly
and then we had a whistleblower come out
don't say his name yes
and he worked with the cia exactly and
he it was it was ridiculous
just absolutely it was the pretext for
impeachment
and now we have you have you seen what
what recently came out with democracy
institute their pollsters they predicted
trump was going to win based on several
metrics
they this guy came out recently on on uh
life
liberty and levin on fox news and said
not only
did uh joe biden or i i shouldn't say
not only but
i'll say this is my personal opinion he
pointed out there are non-polling
bellwether metrics that are never wrong
never wrong like party registration and
voter enthusiasm
never wrong joe biden not only beat
every single bellwether metric that was
against him
he won in almost every single bellwether
area region so you've got the three
bellwether states he lost all of them
and you've got 19 bellwether townships
he he lost 18.
yeah so you you hear about this kind of
stuff
and sam harris i did a segment about
this earlier sam harris was talking
about
he he tweeted uh story from the new york
times why why do people believe the
election was rigged
what rational thinking person hears that
joe biden who didn't campaign who
was in his basement half the time had no
one shoved to his rallies
failed in every bellwether metric so
these are again
registration numbers across the state
the amount of primary votes he got
the uh the media attention he got google
searches he got
mask sales more silly mask and cookie
sales but these do
always show who wins and 18 out of 19
bellwether townships and the three
bellwether states
that all happened ignore all other
accusations of fraud or whatever
and then you come out and say that a
regular person is going to be like
but then he made another a better point
he said show someone the data from the
night of the election
that trump had improved his vote count
among the working class
the white working class minorities the
black community
and they would easily conclude he was
over performing for an incumbent and was
clearly the winner
but after all of that joe biden is the
single greatest president in american
history
who got more votes than barack obama who
had tens of thousands of people rallying
for him one of the most popular
presidents in history
who holds a 95 95 plus approval rating
among democrats
then people say you take that and i'm
not talking about fraud
then you take the down ballot victories
and the oh
the under votes in the hundreds of
thousands for joe biden and then you ask
people if they believe that joe biden
won and they're gonna tell you no i'm
sorry when you say down bout victors
that means a bunch of republicans
the republicans won in every state race
they won every state
they won uh uh they won massive gains in
the house
and are just doing better and better as
time goes on they uh
they held the senate so it was
tremendous
tremendous other pollsters have said
that
this looks like your typical incumbent
victory the incumbent is on the ticket
people go to vote for him and they vote
down ballot in favor of the party so the
party wins
joe biden the greatest president in
american history
congratulations million votes and
historically the incumbent always
usually gets in
except so i'm not i i am not saying any
fraud at all you're just saying aliens
no yes right alien alien no listen
listen what i'm saying right now i am
not accusing anybody of fraud
okay you can talk about the evidence
that's i'm just pointing out
joe biden did all of these things and
that being true these are all true
things
joe biden is the greatest president in
american history period end of question
no that's it that's it that's the only
conclusion is that newsguard approved
yes everything i pointed out is is is is
absolutely fact the bellwether districts
the metrics it's a these are facts
i feel like i just ran have you ever
you've probably experienced this where
you've already worked out florida
hard you work out and you're just you're
done and when nothing matters
you're just so exhausted when trump all
that matters is that you can
relax and that's how i feel about this
election like there's just
how can we do we can't prove anything i
mean maybe that's maybe that's hyperbole
maybe we can prove things
when trump won iowa on election night i
remember when people were like whoa
there it is trump just won iowa
meaningless
yeah i mean there's also talk about
trump literally trying to announce that
he's going to be running for 2024
he said there's there's a video of him
saying it so uh i mean
man we're living in interesting times to
say the least it's ridiculous if look if
everyone that went down went down
trump's not going to win in 2024. if
he's not winning now and everyone else
is it's over and i tell you this i think
the democrats are going to win in
georgia too
if they do that means they're going to
be controlling all of the government
except for the supreme court and this is
not
you're wrong they're going to hack that
immediately if they do pack the courts
yes they're going to have four justices
make it a seven or six checkmate
but doesn't the republicans have the
senate no if they win if the democrats
win the two seats in georgia
the tie breaker is kamala harris oh and
i don't
look the the georgia runoff race trump's
not on the ticket
they needed trump to win it didn't work
in 2018 without trump
the new york times even reported three
recounts now in georgia
sort of sort of trump wants a hard
signature audit where they compare
uh there's also reports that the chain
of custody was broken on absentee
ballots for like a hundred thousand plus
and they just don't care the judges
don't care the judges are like i am not
going to be the person who says
i i object to this right so we would
rather have
these weird like so a a probably
a better example would be the 20 000
names the database from the voter
integrity project of people who
didn't live in georgia lived in other
states and voted twice
the judges in these cases are like i
don't want to hear it i don't want to
hear it
i'm not i'm not getting involved not a
good judge we don't have the judges who
will do anything about it
i'm not saying widespread fraud did
anything other than you know uh
i'm not saying it caused any change in
the election i'm just saying joe biden
is the greatest president in the history
of the united states you mean he got the
most votes
no no the greatest um he hasn't he's not
even president no no no no hold on
a man who doesn't need to campaign all
right to get 80 million votes
truly amazing talking about magnetic oh
yeah
you can point out that people hate trump
but come on man
nobody loves fighting so do you think
it's still going to go to the supreme
court
uh it is so i don't know what the latest
news is because we've been
preparing for this show but tomorrow is
the safe harbor deadline
for uh the electoral college and there
are
active lawsuits in several states so i
don't know if
congress or state legislatures might try
and say
the results were contested the safe hard
harbor deadline passed we did not
certify
uh we did not we not we resolved the
disputes to certification
come on man just the left is arguing
that because they're already certified
we're done the electors are going but in
georgia
they're trying to call a special session
and the governor who's a republican said
no i won't do it
in pennsylvania they tried doing it but
in pennsylvania the supreme court has
requested the response from state
lawyers
as to the constitutionality of mainland
voting by tomorrow morning
arizona we just saw kelly ward uh uh
file to the supreme court of arizona
trying to decertify the results
i'm not saying anything's going to
happen i'm just saying that's where
we're at so far
and tomorrow is probably when we get a
better picture of what's gonna happen
but you know just
across the board every step of the way
trump has been you know kind of losing
out
he's had he's had some major political
victories but he's had major
like legislative failures yeah losses i
should say a lot of people are
describing this as the last
stand that if there's something not
overturned or if the supreme court
doesn't
you know make a decision here that if
the democrats get control of the
congress of the senate
of the white house the house of the
senate and then potentially also the
supreme court if they pack it
it's going to be total game over there's
going to be a lot of open immigration
that's going to turn
a lot of blue cities more blue there's
going to be a lot of
more mailing voting there's going to be
a lot more
change laws that are going to make it
absolutely impossible for another
republican
to uh come in you know you know you know
how a siphon works
no you know how it works um where you
suck on it and then it starts flowing
yeah so uh basically you can take a body
of water at a higher altitude a higher
level
say altitude and uh uh you know and then
you want a tube from there and down what
happens is
once once the water reaches a certain
threshold above
and then goes lower in the tube it pulls
down
creating vacuum force which pulls up the
reason i bring that up is that we are on
the cusp of that water in the siphon
breaking the point by which the water
will never stop flowing and that is if
the democrats
take control of everything like you said
a bunch of open immigration policies
right
which will will continually skew the
country further and further to the left
unraveling it and republicans will only
be able to argue in favor
but less in favor this is why this is
why the democrats love open immigration
one it provides very cheap labor for the
corporations that sometimes are compared
to slave labor because
you don't need to give anyone any
benefits you don't need to give anyone a
living wage
when they're illegal and when they enter
illegally they of course usually
predominantly vote
blue they vote democrats so those
democrats offer them benefits exactly
and protection
exactly or they just pay them under the
table i've seen that happen the
democrats will offer protection
so they'll say like we won't you know in
like sanctuary states like california
for instance
but then what happens is the
corporations in california there's there
was this running scheme they did in in
southern states where
they would put ads out in mexican cities
like small town mexican newspapers
saying
we will pay you a thousand dollars a
month to work in this processing plant
the people would show up and it's a very
very menial job like just take it off
the rack
put it in the machine the machine does
the work just at the end of the month
the company would call ice ice would
show up oh my god arrest them all
send them back there's a lot of evil
corporations taken advantage
of illegal migrants and no one really
wants to talk about it because it goes
against the agenda of
we want more immigration but when we
look at the larger immigration policies
of this country they have extensively
hurt
so many people i remember being in
tijuana during the border crisis when
there was a rush
on the border when they tried to run
through the wall
and i remember being in this kind of
occupied field of individuals that
traveled from nicaragua from honduras
from el salvador
lied to people who were taken advantage
of
every way up every different country
that they went into there was a bunch of
coyotes there's a bunch of cartel
members that
took advantage of them in ways that i
can't even describe here in the show
because of
you know the i'm not youtuber exactly
but talking to these individuals seeing
their hope and like yes i was promised a
job i was promised work i was promised
prosperity
and then let's be honest here when a lot
of them do come they're exploited for
the full benefit of the multinational
corporations
and then these soulless heartless
individuals are or keep promoting come
on in
come right in low information yes these
are the democrats
there's a a i have a family member who's
just like a die-hard
blind neo-liberal doesn't know
anything doesn't read but thinks he's
super smart and it's the perfect example
of of these kind of people who are alike
we want to protect these poor immigrants
and it's like you realize they're being
exploited by massive multinational
corporations who want cheap labor paid
under the table with no benefits
and they're like you just you just
you're racist and i'm like
so hateful this is this is what they do
the democrats will tell you that voter
id is racist
so canada is or canada is water ready
don't they i hope that's
right many countries usually do i have
an idea every other country on the
planet is racist for not for for for
forcing people to identify themselves
there's a famous video of i think about
eight years
of uh of um yes going around
a yuppie area in new york no no no no no
no no he goes to berkeley okay yes yes
and he asks the young berkeley college
students if voter id is racist
and they all say yes for for a variety
of reasons and then he goes to harlem
and he asks black people if it's racist
and they're like no why
yeah and then my favorite bit from this
from the bit is like the arguments
my favorite part of the bit one of the
arguments from the left was
they don't know how to get to the dmv
and so he asks he like walks into this
black dude and he's like
excuse me sir do you know where the dmv
is and he goes oh yeah it's over on 25th
street like the guy was giving him
directions of course he knows where the
dmv
these people are so racist yeah but the
point is when it comes to these policies
that they're implementing the democrats
don't actually
like the regular democratic voters don't
look into what the policies do
it's just an emotional reaction of we
must protect these people
and then it's funny because i see all
these arguments about pro-life versus
pro-choice and they accuse
conservatives of not caring about babies
after they're born and i'm like you
clearly don't talk to any of these
people because they run charities for
these babies
like they donate heavily to this you
don't care about what happens the
migrants if they get here
and they're being run through these
these major corporations that pay them
pennies on the dollar illegally
and don't give them benefits and they
don't have lawyers or access to fight
back
now i know they're nonprofits that help
these individuals too but many of these
voters don't care and know about that
california is the perfect example of
this because when you go to skid row
and you see and you smell and you just
are in this entire mess of of so many
homeless people of so many don trodden
people
that the government can't help and then
you see the latte drinking flip-flop
wearing yuppy saying
come on in come everything's going to be
great everything's going to be fun and
then
you see the ramifications of that
there's not enough
you know let's be honest here there's
not enough resources there are not
enough things that could be done to to
help people a lot of them are left on
their own and when they're left on the
alone though they're screwed and
extorted and exploited by some of the
worst elements of our society
and that needs to be called out and that
needs to be stopped also when you try
and help someone that doesn't want to be
helped i don't know if you guys have
ever done that taking someone into your
house like a sibling
if a country can't even take care of its
own citizens how are they going to take
care of new citizens coming in that's a
great point
but how do you take care of someone that
doesn't want to take care of themselves
important aspect that you brought up
there because a lot of people
don't want the help and they have a
mental health crisis that they're
that this country's dealing with so this
is something jordan peterson talks about
he says to be very careful about helping
people who don't want to be helped
and even people who do want to be helped
because you never know if your help is
actually going to
be useful to them or if you're just
going to make it worse or and it's such
a drain
to help someone i don't know i mean that
is a selfish way of being we're all
pretty selfish as animals we have to
think of ourselves first
and it is exhausting well sometimes you
end up hurting someone more than
actually helping them
and that's you know another important
aspect that you have to kind of consider
and and you know the best thing you
could do is instead of giving someone
fish giving
teach someone how to fish and give them
a fishing pole yes that too that's the
way i put
teach them how to build fishing poles
because uh well then you got to give
them the wood you got it you got to
like teach them how to chop down trees
you got to start from the beginning how
do you
go here's how you take a rock take some
obsidian smash it now you got something
sharp
now you can cut so i always say like you
can you can teach a man a fish feed him
the rest of his life
but if they don't have a fishing pole
you can teach them how to get them a
bunch of fish with their bare hands i
guess
all right we're gonna use the lasers
that's what i think what's missing
because the left says give him fish
the right says keep him to fish and i
say i think the rights got a better
position on this one of teaching people
how to fish
the left says it too i don't want to be
you know overly simplistic but
i think the appropriate response is like
here's a fishing pole buddy here's how
you use it
you're on your own that's it let's let's
okay let's let's jump to the last
segment before we go super chats because
this is huge
ian you're correct good sir i thought so
joe rogan
has removed 1.85
billion views from his youtube channel
whoa
so uh so for those that are listening
ian
he comes to he comes to me earlier and
he says like yo all of joe rogan's
videos are gone
and i said surely you jest good sir ian
joe said that he's gonna keep all of his
episodes on his channel
archived forever and they're they're
gone
most of them most of them are so we
looked into it and there's i don't know
how many
you know 50 plus 1.854 billion so
look we have social blade right here
check this out in in
on december 2nd 1.877 billion views were
subtracted from his channel
and then on december 3rd 53 million so
right just the day after he went
exclusive to spotify
the reason why this matters to a lot of
people and i'm not one for
you know getting into like i don't know
celebrity gossip or anything this is
this is a bit different
and uh i do know joe personally i
haven't asked him about this
but joe is one of the most important
political figures whether he wants to be
or not
there's a reason why the left constantly
wants to cancel him why they they demand
spotify censor him
and now to see that all of these
episodes are gone
and are exclusive to spotify so long as
they still exist i guess i'm happy but
remember
i don't wha did they ever did joe
restore all the episodes that went
missing
i don't know so so here's the here's the
original story right
joe goes to spotify transfers over the
podcasts and then a bunch of episodes
didn't transfer over
and people noticed that these episodes
were very interestingly from certain
people
alex jones gavin mcginnis i think um
people like that kayla peterson yeah
yeah yeah
but but my understanding was that it was
a it was an error of some sort but don't
worry
every episode will be available forever
on youtube i see that that's not the
case anymore check it out i'll
pull it to youtube when you go to his
actual channel
so i've sorted by oldest you can see the
oldest he's got these videos from back
in the day seven years ago but
it's just i i don't understand you know
why these specific videos i guess these
are all the biggest
podcasts ever yeah like 4.4 million
views and more and higher
yeah i mean this is a shame i mean the
conversations the comments the views
uh a lot of people utilize those you
know in their lives and they were very
important for so many people and now to
see them gone it's
it's a little disappointing to me i
guess they're on spotify
my is my guess i tried to i want to
point people to david sinclair joe rogan
uh the second one where sinclair is like
a life extension guy from harvard he's
awesome david sinclair
so i did this show on saturday with um
seth from venice beach dub club shout
out south
and talked about david sinclair and then
i went to rogan's channel right after
that and that's when i found out
it was gone there's a lot of people also
saying that this is because
joe rogan is allegedly having a hard
time translating his youtube audience
into spotify
there's a couple articles wow talking
about that there's one here by
sportscuta.com that says it's titled joe
rogan fans are refusing to follow him to
spotify
and it's bad so you know they outline
how a lot of people are just
aren't translating so so actually i have
i have a a couple articles i've got from
uh
dexertoe.com joe rogan fans outraged her
podcast moves exclusively to spotify
i thought that was kind of silly though
because we knew he was going to do it
but
now i see exactly why people are
probably really angry
getting all the episodes pulled from the
biggest podcast in the world
it was just an incredible trove of
information it's maybe sad
sad loss and i imagine he's just private
he's just probably private at all
maybe joe uh they're they're they're
gone from his channel the views have
been removed
but that makes sense if people so check
this out we have a story from the new
york post this is from
aurora why the left is lashing out at jo
i'm sorry this is the wrong one i i need
to go to the fans one right
why the fans are upset they say as of
december 2nd
full episode of the podcast are
exclusively available on spotify and
highlight clips
will appear on on youtube in the
comments section of the youtube clip
fans release release their frustration
towards the exclusive move
it's been a hell of a ride guys see ya
one viewer said one fan said bye to the
podcast in their comment
this feels like a breakup and i feel
cheated for a richer guy
by jre another disappointed viewer
revealed that while they tried listening
to the show on spotify they couldn't
handle the 10 straight minutes of ads
that's kind of silly because if you've
ever listened to the actual podcast on
itunes or whatever he has ads running on
it so most people probably don't care
they're going to say the move over to
spotify certainly brought about some
dissatisfaction
but that's the interesting point maybe
because
that's what you mentioned right because
he couldn't generate he couldn't get
enough people to translate over
yes he takes the videos off of youtube
he wasn't going to do that originally
but maybe spotify said yo we're not
getting big viewership on spotify
well spotify again invested a lot into
joe rogan and there was a lot of
internal battles and fights that they
had to clear up
internally just to just to get this joe
rogan train running
and yeah this the employees kept
revolting yes which was
uh pretty ridiculous to think an
individual has
the power to you know control what you
could listen to or not to listen to it's
so obnoxious it's so egotistical
it's just utterly insane but they
started moving
the podcast and making them exclusive on
december 1st so it's only been a few
days since this has been happening
so the other episodes were supposed to
stay as an archive forever yes
but i'm saying through this transition
there could be some kind of
rearrangement saying
we might not be getting the views we
want one of the videos on the
on spotify had 1.8 million views which
is
actually not you can see the viewership
uh this is what the
sports keita is reporting that his
latest video has 1.8 million views
so that's still pretty good was that
moxie marlon spike um i'm not sure he's
gonna say that old dude no no offense
dude
thank you but white hair to solder
what's the process to sign up to spotify
do you need to pay for a membership do
you need to like
you so i think for uh
you might have to sign in for the roman
podcast i'm not sure yes
uh i know that it's free it's free if
you want to listen to it
but uh i'm not sure if you have to sign
in to listen to it i think
you probably do to watch too is it is it
and then you can watch it no comments
right people were like there's no
comments on spotify is that true yeah no
comments wow that's a big change
right and that's why clearly youtubers
are upset yeah one of the reasons why
you know so many people loved the joe
rogan podcast was when it was live
people were able to talk to each other
uncensored and there was just doubt
average of like
so many people talking all at once and a
lot of people got a lot of good
information from the comment section i
thought he disabled comments
he did but his previous videos
had had the comments going through it
and then after the video was done
everyone was able to comment i'm gonna
pop comment it was voted up i'm gonna be
completely honest with everybody
uh everybody knows i know joe it's cool
dude we we i talk to him fairly often
um i think i think he got an amazing
deal i guess it was reported in the wall
street journal
like 100 million bucks no no i can
clearly understand why i took it
but i think to be totally honest one of
the things that helped joe remain on top
as the biggest podcast in the world
was that he was the first in it's it was
saying his first and
best dressed what happens is joe works
ever his show is consistent was it
monday through thursday new episode
never misses a beat he he puts it up on
itunes
when when podcasts are first coming out
he was doing podcasts before podcasts
were a thing
so when people are first getting
introduced to podcasting they open their
iphone
they click the podcast button and
there's joe rogan the first thing they
see
free advertising on the most prominent
podcasting app
that's true for youtube as well he's
been on the platform for a really long
time
the algorithm loves long-form content
and clips with high engagement
so youtube's promoting him like crazy
and he was getting algorithmic boosts
it was authentic it wasn't poppy it
wasn't corporate it wasn't disney
it was him talking about guerrilla dmt
monkeys ripping each other to shreds
which is fascinating to to listen to it
was fun and then he did it but one thing
i have to give him props for is he did
it in a way where
he wasn't he wasn't cocky about it he
wasn't
uh you know elitist about it it was him
discovering
information learning and taking you
along the process
as he was learning it and that's what
really drove a lot of people to listen
because they wanted to join that
authentic
real honest conversation that you can't
get anywhere else because most news guys
are there with the suit and they have
their little monotone but
right right but listen listen we uh what
we do on this show
is derivative of what joe started doing
10 years ago yeah
and so i think about someone like casey
neistat you guys know you know
vlogger he was the first vlogger to
actually make
cinematic editing you know in his vlogs
before him it was like
a dude with a cell phone walking around
talking about their day they were
getting a
crazy viewership then casey comes around
and he's like i'm going to put my camera
down
turn it on then leave the room and then
walk back in to get to this like edit
play music time lapses and all of a
sudden his channel skyrocketed to 10
million subs in a very short amount of
time he made hbo documentaries before
doing the vlog right so he was a
professional he yeah right it was
beautiful what he did but so here's what
happens at a certain point
everybody is making identical vlogs to
him and
then it dilutes the market share so like
what i'm kind of getting at is of course
joe rogan is completely unique
superstar mma comedian he's a really
funny guy he's got his talent
but i think what was really keeping him
in the top spot was the fact that
he was given this prominent real estate
by being first and best dressed
i'm not saying that you know uh his show
is going to fail by any means i'm just
saying
a large portion of the viewership was
was is due to algorithms and i'll admit
this for myself too because i'm not
trying to drag anybody else
i know for a fact the youtube algorithm
drives the majority of my content
the reason you are all probably
listening to this right now is because
it popped up on your front page when you
went to youtube.com
you thought this is interesting
conversation by joe rogan you clicked it
many of you probably aren't even
subscribed
you just happen to be passing by a large
portion of your ship are from
non-subscribers
and it's because the algorithm chose to
promote you subscribe by the way youtube
totally controls who sees your videos
and who doesn't and that main
front screen on youtube.com determines
everything
it used to be with the amount of views
so it used to be loose change came out
and that was the number one viewed video
it was out number one platform
now it's all algorithms do you know
deciding what's good for you
i was going to ask you what do you think
is the current
the the best first and best dressed now
do you have there is no first in okay
unless we do like like first in is like
when this first started when podcasting
became a thing
joe was already there and he had a show
that was really interesting
is there anyone that is doing any
content right now that you could say is
similar we're we're well past that point
of getting the initial boost
yeah so now it's just we're all at a
party if someone wants to jump up and
down and scream and get attention they
can there was like
but i want to tell people hard numbers
take a look at the view count on this
video
okay for those that are watching live
you're going to see i think we've got
around you know 46 000 or so people
i think when all is said and done this
episode's going to have around 200
or like 300 maybe 400 000 viewers it
depends you know um
three to six viewership yeah yeah
sometimes they're bigger
but when they're like just running the
run of the you know like our average
episodes will probably hit around four
hundred thousand
you wanna know how much they get on all
podcast platforms combined
35 35 000. and guess what
one of the top global podcasts we are
ranked i think top uh 230
biggest podcast in the world but we're
getting this 1000 percent more views on
youtube well uh
10 ten times a thousand right right
you're right you're right
uh on my show on the tim pool daily show
i get uh between the three videos maybe
like
you know two or three million views a
day or more actually yeah it's way more
than that
i was getting around i've kind of
lowered the amount of content i was
doing but i was getting
about you know four to five million
views on my youtube content every day
the podcast ranked at its peak number 34
itunes top charts in the world seventy
thousand
wow that that's that's how dramatically
different the numbers are
compared to youtube so i bring that up
because
i think by taking these videos off
youtube and by leaving youtube
and and i mean this with the most
respect for you know joey's a friend uh
i think he's gonna lose a ton of
influence but i'm not i'm not entirely
convinced that something he cares about
to be honest yeah i mean he he cashed
out
kudos good good job he's starting his
own comedy club i think he wants to do
exactly what he wants to do without
negotiating the network of
comedy and tech i mean listen listen so
awesome guaranteed income
no banning and so spotify is up spotify
he's the biggest
number one on spotify and his clips are
still on youtube on the jru channel so
we're still putting clips with links to
his spotify content and the clips are
still getting
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
views so maybe maybe he's just
diversifying is uh
it's true but the big issue i guess is
you know at the end of the day joe's got
to do what's good for joe
he's just a guy he's doing his thing and
you can't expect anything from him
there's a lot of people who they they
looked up to him as an important figure
in in the culture because
joe wouldn't just go along blindly with
he doesn't just go along blindly
with this you know with what's going on
in left or right or whatever
he's just like a regular guy who will
challenge things they don't seem to make
sense and he'll call out people on his
own show for it as much as the left
tries to argue he doesn't
losing him in the most prominent
positions of the culture war
scares a lot of people and i'm sure the
left is clapping and cheering the whole
time
and they're trying to use that now that
change to get them banned off spotify
too yeah we have to understand here
there was a lot of establishment
pressure a lot of pressure from the
mainstream media a lot of
you know pressure from what people would
consider the ruling class to get him
canceled to get him
kicked off of youtube so this could be
another reason why he moved over to
spotify where as you said that can't be
censored
and uh i think that's something
important to really consider here they
were also going after his
friends on his show oh of course that
was crazy nearly 2 billion views removed
from his channel
i wonder if all of those have translated
over to to this to spotify
you know i got i got to be honest though
uh i don't get nearly
any views on spotify or downloads for
the podcast it's it's negligible
i don't even bother with it there's
nothing i can do i mean look if you're
listening right now
hop over to spotify give us a good
review on itunes we continually are
going up in the rankings people are
subscribing people are following people
are leaving you know good reviews and
good comments
and i can see like a month ago this show
wasn't even in the top charts
and now it's officially correct it's
it's the itunes top 250 is their
official like breakdown for the top
podcasts
and now we're we're doing it spotify
nothing is there a link to spotify
on the youtube video no that's that'll
probably work
some videos uh he's saying go check out
our full episodes on spotify so that
does happen
to me this is kind of very similar to a
move we see done by howard stern
when he moved over from you know regular
radio facing pressure from the ftc
uh and all the other government agencies
and he just moved over to
yeah but what's he what's he's gone yeah
what's his his relevance is
i know it's like the value of money and
the value of rel
of like personal relevance to society
and this is the great
you know lesson of our time and joe's in
the middle of it so i'm going to be
happy to hear his look on it in the
future looking
back he's got no obligation to anybody
but himself that's true you know so if
he says he's going to take
a a good deal and then look i i know a
lot of people are angry because
he is a powerful everyman who when he
has conversations about social justice
warriors and like authoritarianism
he's far from conservative but he's like
that's that's bs i'm not going to play
that game he talks about fun interesting
things
to have him move away to an exclusive
platform is like it's devastating for
the culture war it's
it's a huge win for the leftists no
doubt i want to see howard stern and
rogan do something now
i don't know i i doubt howard stern
could big daddy stern got us got his
contract
oh yeah but he also became kind of
establishment yeah he totaled his dad
can he not say anything on the show he
denied ever saying racial slurs like in
this one segment and then they played it
for him and he was like i'm so sorry i
did that
no no joke howard stern apologizing
for being a shock jockey so if someone
offered you 100 million would you jump
i you have obligation to i guess i i got
to be real though i
i probably wouldn't i probably would not
that's a lot of money
yeah but what am i going to do with it i
don't know
that's what i'm saying like what's the
question if you have something to do
with it then i can see going for it
create a beanie school where you teach
other beanie wearers to be
truth speakers listen listen let's start
with our own youtube channels right now
we're talking about getting a hundred
acre farm
in in central west virginia middle of
nowhere
hours from anything and like the agents
are like you really don't want to be
here there's no there's nothing and it's
like oh yeah that's exactly what we want
to build we're going to build our own
space out you know how much you know do
you know how much 100
acres can cost if you go to like montana
or something it's like
nothing couple hundred bucks a month on
a mortgage and you can have
a hundred two hundred acres of just big
open empty land
so if you wanna do something you you
could really just do it
it's not the most difficult thing i mean
obviously if you're younger it's a lot
harder you got to save up money
clearly that's you know when i was
younger i worked fast food i worked you
know crummy jobs and just saved
everything i could
the main important thing that people
need to realize is one of the most
important things you could do is
enjoy yourself whatever you're doing
whatever you're working towards if
you're enjoying yourself keep on doing
it
so i think that's essentially what i
think is going down to
to to rogan's decision he likes doing
them
he likes doing the podcasts there's a
lot less pressure on him to
to for it to be taken down and he's
going to continue his own way
and as just as you said he has no
obligation to any of us yeah and
that's that's an important realization
that a lot of people need to make
stop looking up to idols or other
individuals don't put any man above
yourself
you yourself have to look up to yourself
internally and always
build yourself up as much as you can i
will say this though you know
trying to be respectful because again i
know joe i'm not trying to drag him or
anything but
when you tell everybody don't worry the
episodes are going to be archived
forever they'll always exist you can
watch them whenever you want on youtube
and then you take them all off people
are going to be like yo
yeah that's kind of i never heard him
say that he did say that specifically
i thought that's what the deal was i was
always so vague i didn't know
plus he was like beholden to ad revenue
before and now
he's not now he gets it ahead of time so
he can just kind of
so you guys can correct me if i'm wrong
but going to something like spotify like
joe did it seems kind of to me like a
soft retirement
it really seems like a semi-retirement
he's kind of done he just wants to chill
he doesn't have to worry about youtube
and all this
could be but at the same time he did
want to host a joe biden
versus a donald trump president if
you're hosting a huge presidential
debate you're not riding off into the
sunset
how much you're putting yourself in the
spotlight how much of that was him just
like you know in the moment
no i mean you saw it in his eyes he was
excited he wanted it he was like i want
donald trump here joe biden here and
alex jones talking about dmt in the
corner
i want it right now and and america
would have loved that and we deserved
that
maybe maybe look maybe spotify will take
over take over itunes because of joe
that's the bet right but they also don't
have a good record when it comes to
upholding people's spotify is still
google
yes it's alphabet oh it is and and they
have a bad record of censoring speech
yeah yeah you know that's another aspect
that we have to
understand here it might just be
everything you know look man
eventually you're not uh 19 year old
hungry kid anymore who's trying to take
over the world you're in your 50s you've
got a family and you're like how long am
i going to be leading the charge on this
one and
yeah i heard him make a comment that
like telling his family yo guys it's
time to party
we got the payout let's let's roll like
just but here's let's let's
let's have that serious question what do
you do with a hundred million dollars
wealth management and then just becomes
infinite money for you in the long run
you've broken through this barrier where
once i think john mccain was asked this
in 2008 or whatever 2007 how much money
do you need
to be truly wealthy he's at 7 million
dollars and then there was this guffaw
from the media like oh
seven million if you if i was a
millionaire no no what he was saying was
at that time with seven million bucks
you put it in a wealth management
you know account or like you you get a
wealth manager you're rich forever you
never have to work again
if you could yeah you're like a wall
street banker just creating money out of
thin air yeah with all their
derivatives and all the other
complicated language they make for
literally monopoly money
what do you do with the money probably
buy a bunch of lasers and start
launching a satellite
dude slicing super soldiers security
guards start building
that's expensive okay we can invest in
like lasers aren't that expensive
we can invest in lunar um space
elevators
and like nah that's interesting elon
musk but
from uh facebook and paypal and
literally started a space program and
he's trying to go mars so
a lot less than 100 million i think at
the time i don't know but his he put his
net worth on the line basically is joe
rogan going to create a space program
that'd be cool i think he's going to
send a chimp into space jump research
in space comedy people into space
dude it's a lot funnier when there's no
gravity it's like twenty thousand
dollars to do a space tourism
you got a hundred million bucks you got
a lot of space tourism you can do it and
now where we've got re-entry
rockets we can utilize um people going
out of space for a zero g
comedy show that'd be awesome just like
grazing for like 20 minutes and
i wonder what left what would you like
if you had 100 million dollars what
would you do
uh first thing i would do is invest
about 20 million of it into
cryptocurrency
okay um the second thing i would do is
start researching uh satellites and
start launching satellites
with like ionic thrusters and and
propellers to get them up out of orbit
and then start making well elon's
already doing global internet
yeah so i'd like to enhance the global
internet program i would start putting
water wells around the world
i would solar-powered i would do a free
speech internet
just all out just like it was before
that's my thing sorry i cut you off
we could do that with the internet but
you don't need 100 million dollars to do
that
you do now with the infrastructure that
google has
yeah they can seize your domain yeah but
that's why you have 100 million dollars
to make sure you create a system
outside of that system where it's not
the internet used to be such a wild
incredible awesome place when you
clicked on something you didn't know
what you're going to get
but it was going to rattle your brain it
was going to make you think it was going
to inspire you
now it's just the same squeegee clean
complaining moaning and whining by
boomers and by
uh i don't want to mention someone
specifically i was going to do that
but there's so much trash out there when
it comes to just
selling you products and just the same
squeegee clean
same youtube video that you just keep
seeing repeated over and over again
there needs to be a day where there
isn't anything curated and controlled
and regulated
where it's wild and it's free and it's
real and if i had 100 million dollars i
would literally spend it i'll tell you
guys
creating that i'll tell you guys a
secret the secret is
money can make you happy up to a certain
point like you don't have to worry about
starving to death or you know you're not
anxious and sitting there shaking
because you're going to get evicted
but for the most part what truly makes
you happy is purpose yeah purpose can
come from a
from friends from family and from a
mission but a hundred million dollars is
not purpose exactly if someone just gave
you a hundred million dollars you
probably would not be happy
and people don't realize this yes you
you get to the like and i don't look i
fully i am not some
you know far right you know or far left
i understand that there are people who
can't pay their bills and are desperate
and scared and struggling
money can make them reach a certain
threshold of contentment
but i have a friend who became
multi-millionaire when he was 16 years
old
by writing a computer code that just
ended up generating a bunch of money
about the company
made millions of dollars and then when
he was like 19 in an existential crisis
because there was nowhere left for him
to go he was already the top of his
field everybody i knew he was
there was there was nothing that he
could do like he he was he was exactly
he was doing what he wanted to do
everybody knew he was he had all this
money and he ended up talking to a bunch
of other rich people who said
that once they get to that point where
they have so much money everything just
kind of stops
you have an existential crisis because
you've done it what is what's left
yes there's actually a phenomenon with a
lot of people who win the lottery that
literally lose all of their money within
a few years
so that keeps happening again and again
and a lot of them report
not being happier because of that money
so they keep only having more
problems and a lot of people think that
they could fill in this psychological
empty void that has been put into us by
the controllers
as i would metaphorically say they think
just by
the culture of consumerism by doing what
you're told by spending money on where
the cool kids spend them everything's
going to be different it's not people
need to wake up from that reality
stop buying into this consumerism of
nike slave made
chinese factory produced sneakers that
supports people like lebron james
they'll lecture you
about black lives matter meanwhile when
actual human rights are being violated
by his company
and the hundreds of millions of dollars
that he's receiving he's not going to
say jack or
iota about that actual issue that does
enslave and hurt people
to an effect that we can't even imagine
i'm reminded of that scene from fight
club
where they're in the car and the two
guys are in the back and then he takes
his hands off the wheels and he's like
if you were to die what's one thing you
would have regret not having done
and one guy's like paint a portrait or
paint a self-portrait the guys build the
house
you got to think about that stuff mine
is what you want to do build a rail
cannon that we can use to launch
satellites like it's underground about
100 yards and then it
curves and then goes up and then so you
just now if you remember
launched these lightweight satellites we
had these we had these same
conversations
before disney and before vice i was like
don't do it man
don't go for the man don't go to but
your strategy
where you are right now is something
commendable yeah you were wrong
you were wrong no i was right and you
even told me there's a video
where we talked you were like yeah man
you're all right you were telling me not
to be with the corporations
they were gonna control me and they were
going to stifle me
and i think you could have even been
bigger and stronger
if you weren't you're correct with vice
if you weren't with disney which i've
been telling you don't do it
don't go with them be independent be
free and then as soon as you came out of
that corporate hell hole
you blossomed and you're here today as
one of the top political
youtubers and you have to give you know
props to that but at the same time they
did stifle you
and i told you when i was first starting
youtube
i was making like five bucks a week and
it was impossible
i was making pyro books for one two when
i started advice
i had to ask them to for front me the
first paycheck said no money left
and so i was like that's it i can't it's
it's it was it was it was you know money
it was going down for a while covering
protests around the country
people would donate and that was a slow
upward trajectory but once protests
started spacing out and slowing down
my costs uh were you know
more than the opportunities to actually
cover news and generate some kind of
revenue
trust me i was there i was sleeping on
couches i knew you know many times in
circumstances that i'm not going to have
any money in the bank
i took a job and uh and i saved all the
money from it
and then once i finally left when i left
disney i went to these other companies
i'm not going to name them but you can
probably guess a lot of what they were
you know with all these different
companies
and then i was like i got money in the
bank now yeah i'm going to do whatever i
want
i i was able to fly to sweden i was able
to fly to europe and travel around
because i didn't have to worry about
that anymore it was it was me working
these jobs allowing me to have the
investment
to start my own companies my approach
was a little different but each his own
we're here today and we still have a
voice you went like
full independent full independent full
what was your history like from the
beginning like when you were 16
i mean i was working full-time going to
school full-time and
still doing activism and then alex jones
saw some of the videos i did
and um you know
look
that's debatable there is a contested
history we're not on good terms now and
it's fine i don't hold any grudges or
anything personal
but we definitely went our separate ways
because we have we have a different way
of doing things
and you know whatever uh you know things
happen uh
but uh you never see goldeneye yeah you
know at the end so basically what
happened was they were actually at the
satellite
and luke was hanging by one hand and
then he looked up at alex
and then alex had his foot on his hand
and luke goes for 911 truth alex
and alex goes no for me kicks him off
and looks
falls down there was a big fight and it
was very entertaining and uh
wow i'm not going to share too much
personal details i don't hold any
grudges i concentrate on my mission
and my mission is to do as much research
as much homework as i can find out
anything i can that's useful to people
and to share it with them that's my
main goal that's my main mission that's
what i set my life's purpose to be
and that's what i focus on not e-drama
and all this other stuff that's uh you
know outside of the focus
well just two quick things one i kind of
want to watch goldeneye but
i love that movie we gotta do super
chats did you make it we played the
video of the woman
shooting uh the intruder we're we're
we're 15 minutes
the answer is yes and the answer is
we're 15 minutes past
and i also have a question did you do
what documentary did you do did you do a
really popular one in the past
well there was the the loose change kids
and i helped help them with that and
there were some of my video video video
footage in there and i was with them
from the very beginning
yeah that was like groundbreaking all
right super chats if you haven't already
get your super chats in
we'll read as much as i can obviously i
can't read everybody's but also smash
the like button
uh and you know just comment subscribe
notification bell the good stuff
brian says hey tim love the show do i
have your blessing to perform your song
will of the people for my audition for
the voice on friday it's an amazing song
of course you do absolutely
however i'm pretty sure that preliminary
auditions they make you sing the song
they want you to sing
so i knew people who have auditioned for
american uh
american idol and they actually
initially give you a song it's a generic
like pop song they tell you to sing it
and then they choose you based on
whether or not you're entertaining on tv
that's about it so stay loose when you
go in there but prep will other people
kale yamamoto says i can tell alex jones
is really starting to rub off on tim
lately
alex didn't talk to me about aliens at
all we talked about
oh we used to talk about this stuff all
the time yeah he doesn't really talk
about aliens
no mike c says if you've seen rick and
morty you know what the deal is with the
galactic federation
you know i love that show okay so
someone actually uh mentioned
early on about joe rogan michael anthony
lewis says joe rogan very recently said
only 100 episodes will remain on youtube
when he recently appeared on the alex
jones podcast oh i didn't realize he
wanted alex
oh interesting so we'll have to keep
make sure that in any clip we'll put
that in the notes all right let's see
jacob
says please tell me that you're going to
talk about the woman who was arrested
for admitting on facebook and instagram
that she and her daughter worked at a
vote counting center in georgia and
committed fraud
i'm not uh she was arrested for that i
haven't seen that that's crazy yeah you
want to go
look it up a woman and her daughter in
in georgia
admitted on facebook dylan keller says i
don't care if aliens are hiding
technology from us we are humans
we'll discover it eventually if they
don't want to talk to us it's their loss
we'll make our own galactic federation
with blackjack
and hookers that's right on the moon
with bender do you think that if we were
all
tripping that we'd have quicker access
to aliens
if we were tripping like if we took
psychedelic drugs no that's inside
i think psychedelic drugs can be
beneficial uh uh
based on the research honestly in like
small doses in specific circumstances
but if people were always tripping
they'd never get anything maybe if we
all tripped it once
i don't like the word tripping because
that's implies you're falling over on
yourself but i did read a study about a
bunch of scientists who all micro dosed
lsd and then like ended up accomplishing
a bunch of like
like goals of theirs or something and
also like group meditation is pretty
powerful there are some scientific
studies that do
talk about uh dosing and having a lot of
breakthroughs
so that's yeah there's something to
think about
the smartest idiot says as a fellow
human flesh ape i welcome our future
floorbo
floorbow overlords oh it's a step ahead
xavier says can someone tell me what the
heck is going on just at the egg i don't
know what that is
someone has a very spicy comment i can't
read it but i will mention there's a
spicy comment
it's about a guy whose name is jeffrey
oh ashley says hi gang alien
confirmation
sounds like a misdirection to change the
confirmation
conversation conversation yeah honest
honestly that's uh uh that's a good
point
we got all this voter fraud stuff going
on all sudden this guy's like oh aliens
i'll tell you i have more fun tonight
then yeah yeah
and then we had those stupid monoliths
popping up everywhere yeah and
everyone's like
don't don't look at the election look at
the shiny the meme of the guy with the
monolith in his toilet
yeah yeah that was funny literally a
shiny object
come on oh yeah come on guys omega
hunter says tim
earlier this year you were talking about
how the insanity level was was
increasing for 2020
and you mentioned one of the next steps
seemingly ingest would be aliens
so let me ask you did you get this info
from a terrestrial source it was a meme
there's a meme yeah you posted it where
it's like a calendar like of all the
months yeah
like what's going on oh babylon b had
one yes yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like
aliens come in june and then you like
but never happened you know months off
yeah the civic nationalist says tim
divine right was an excuse by kings
because their ancestors
were the strongest league of nations was
1919 after world war one ah thank you
for the correction
and burn the heretic kill the mutant
purge the unclean so league of nations
after world war one but that was like a
general idea like we don't want world
war something like that that's right
i believe that was correct and then
there was a world war yes yes there were
because of the league of nations here we
go super 503 dank says so tim what
you're saying is the aliens are behind
intersectionality
that way we are all featureless
genderless ready for the galactic
federation
yes with shaven heads wearing gray
jumpsuits with no pockets
that's right that's exactly what's going
to be like and big heads yes
doobie mcnasty says would it be crazy if
humans came together for world peace
just so that we could meet the aliens i
mean that'd be cool i guess that's an
idea
i'm into it i think it's worth
considering that'd be awesome neon light
says shout out to charles the stinkbug
loved his commentary on his evolutionary
adaptation yes
charles could you i wonder if you could
even you can hear anything from him i
don't think charles is that his name
morgan hengel says i would love to have
a conversation with an alien i feel that
our perspective on common is uh
perspective on common issues
will be vastly different due to
technological and cultural differences
i mean also uh environmental and
evolutionary yeah what if they don't eat
matter the way we do
what if they're like plants what if they
have to spend like
a month just sitting still absorbing
solar radiation to move around for one
day what would you ask an alien if you
only had like 10 seconds
how much wood could a woodchuck chuck of
woodchuck could just
of course good question he could tell
how much wood
would a woodchuck chuck how many lows
would rob lowe
how many lows could rob low rob if roblo
i can't do it good rob
how many lows could rob lowe rob if rob
lowe could rob lowe's there we go
that's my favorite tongue twister oh my
gosh i'm not even gonna get into a good
one
i'd ask um what's the meaning of life
42.
that's a lot of questions i don't think
there was an actual question
yeah there was no question what's the
ultimate and the question answer the
ultimate question like
the question is sometimes when i ask
cats questions they get
confused like questions is kind of a
human thing
i wonder if other animals don't think in
terms of that probably not they're just
in fact
filthy jim has a question okay he says
what's your thoughts on the mud flood
and tartaria
we we talk a lot about that actually
here in this house oh yeah it seems like
throughout history
the victor has written history and
covered up the past
and that has also happened with mud
floods like atlanta seems to be covered
by mud
um so i think a lot of ancient
technology has been lost
to to mud and then
and then the people don't want to so for
those who are not familiar with this
conspiracy theory
it's that there was a great planetary
civilization right
atlantis at least yeah and then tartary
the tartar
and they got wiped out in a mud flood a
giant flood and the mud
buried a bunch of buildings and then
there was a war
over the ancient technology and the
victors changed history so that we
didn't realize we're actually
discovering the remnants of an ancient
civilization
the tartars were actually came from the
barbers which means
foreigner barbarian met foreigner and so
these tartars were like
theoretically slaughtered by like the
the asians and russians and then
we're kind of we're told to forget about
this ancient euro-asian
gigantic you know civilization of
tartaria
darius harvey says metal gear solid
perfect soldier big boss is unable to
have children
a shadow government wants an heir so
they clone him three sons are born
the answer to not tainting the gene pool
make all three infertile
super soldiers are also infertile well
there you go yeah
the chinese super soldiers they could
specifically i think they're going to be
reproducing a lot especially with the
shortage
of it's going to be like fallout the
super mutants
you know where they're like gigantic
genderless monsters
probably there you go it is trendy now
cordy on ice says sargon's episodes with
joe rogan aren't on spotify or
youtube wow there it is sam carl
benjamin
has been axed from the joe rogan show
car
it's over no see there you go that's
that's kind of messed up man yeah
i mean i'm sure it exists somewhere
though someone downloaded it somewhere
sure
yeah bit shoot isn't that where they get
i mean somebody had to have archived
this i think when when it was when
people saw that joe's episodes weren't
porting over
some of them everyone immediately went
and archived every episode
but there you go right there he's been
unpersoned wow that's crazy
tom dimartino says tim i think joe's
videos are probably unlisted now and not
deleted
my theory is that the entire spotify
play is a youtube flex
and the entire podcast will be back to
youtube eventually i i don't think so i
actually had that thought that i don't
once his contract with spotify runs out
he'll
make everything public again on youtube
i wonder
i mean listen joe can't do this show
forever
is joe gonna be like a 70 year old man
being like yes you guys ever tried to
he's gonna be young
he's gonna be one of those 90 year old
50 year olds yeah he really is
i could see it he's younger than he was
two years ago i know right it's crazy
he's going backwards he supplements a
lot
jamie what pull that up man
old jamie old jamie and old joe
a.g birch says jre is popular because he
respects cats
that may be where your crowd comes from
too tim that's right but but luke
doesn't i do not
he doesn't okay there's a lot of
taxoplasmy everywhere and
there needs to be toxoplasmosis yeah
it's in potato potatoes dustin works as
ian check out walter vice on secret
societies
he shows you with evidence all roads
lead to rome with the fed
tim realize that klaus schwab already
said the fourth industrial revolution is
humans changing
dude this guy sounds legit yep in the
world economic forum talked about
implants and using biotech technologies
in in order to help advanced human
civilization
so it's your neural link yeah well elon
musk is literally working on a microchip
that you put inside of your brain don't
you want to be able to plug into the
matrix and learn kung fu in five seconds
i am okay oh i am so ready kung fu i
don't want to wire myself
would you rather be given unlimited
money or would you rather work towards
having the money that you earned and
worked hard for yourself
um that's a tough question exactly
would you rather get a fish or would you
have a fishing pole well if you had a
choice if you had a choice
let me answer go ahead i'm saying it's a
tough question because i'm not thinking
about being given money
i wouldn't want to be given a ton of
money because money doesn't get you what
you want
but in terms of being able to instantly
know kung fu versus having to train for
years to be good at kung fu
i kind of want to just be good at kung
fu what would make you happier
what would make you more satisfied if
right now they were like press enter and
you'll be a kung fu master i would be
stoked on that
then it gets old and it's like no it
wouldn't get old because i wouldn't be
doing kung fu
every day i would be going about my
normal business that i want to go about
but just knowing kung fu but if you have
to work hard for it every single day you
would appreciate it i think some people
want what's your favorite what's your
under misunderstanding is that
i am currently not doing kung fu because
i don't care that much
if i was given the ability to just learn
kung fu instantly the matrix style
and it was passive i'd totally do it i'd
be stoked yeah but then you would take
that to every element of your life
and then you would be spoiled no you
wouldn't yeah you would i think you
would
some people you wouldn't respect any you
wouldn't need you wouldn't give a damn
about anything
it's like having the cheat codes you had
a video game that's hard when it's hard
it's actually really fun to play when
you have all the cheat codes but what if
the cheat code
that you can change the color of your
shoes you're going to be like well now
i'm playing the game but the game's the
same
if you have a cheat code to do anything
right but i'm not talking about one
specific thing
i'm talking about everything i'm saying
that if right now
in the context of my life kung fu would
not help me complain on the internet
i would totally be down to just
instantly learn kung fu
what do you do who would you use against
what i wouldn't i just run around doing
front flips and stuff
that's not really kung fu you know i
spent the first 40 years of my life in
hard mode
working hard and i'm now i know so many
geniuses that i want to fly out here to
build the laser
that i need unlimited money so i would
take the unlimited money cheat
will there be sharks with lasers on top
of them i'm into it okay
all right we got a uh a really good
point here from clef the misfit he says
unexpected election outcome
trump wins his lawsuits which drives
democrat rage turnout in georgia winning
them the senate seats
dems then impeach and remove trump and
pence pelosi becomes president
it's actually a really good point if
trump does win this fight
that means the democrats are definitely
going to win in georgia and they will
impeach and remove trump
oh no no no i'm sorry that can't work
sorry wait that's not possible
but pelosi is the president we need no
no stop stop this is wrong
sorry clef you're completely incorrect
the democrats can only
tie the senate right now if trump wins
his lawsuits tiebreaker goes to trump
and if they tried to impeach trump then
pence would would break the tie
defending
pence and trump so that can't happen
okay thank goodness
yeah all right let's see we got a bunch
of new super chats
andrew mike says hello all i think the
gop will win in georgia
democrats are low information it will be
hard to get them to come out again
trump not on the ballot will hurt damn
turnout that's a good point harder to
cheat this time thoughts
thanks for all your hard work i actually
said without trump on the democrats
would win
actually it might be the other way
around without trump on the bout they're
going to be like i don't care
if you were here hey it's the
republicans freaking out right now
you know hate vote was strong yeah megan
stewart says joe biden did not campaign
but he did pay ariana grande and a bunch
of other influencers to campaign to
their audiences to vote for him that's a
good point yeah
but uh i think i i listen okay joe biden
is the greatest president of this one
that's unsaid wasn't cardi b also
endorsed no bernie
no no no and then she did an interview
with but i want you to think about this
joe biden didn't campaign he didn't hold
big rallies
he simply appeared you know i know i
know what one i know what did it what
was it his beautiful eyes carter
the pressure oh that was that was the
activation word for all of those who
have been programmed by the tvs
right so so for the past uh for the past
four years the tv
has been subliminally saying when you
hear the code word you will vote for joe
biden
true in on a shabbata pressure true in a
nana shabbat of pressure and then
finally one day everyone's sitting there
and then joe biden goes turn it on a
shot with a pressure and then like some
dude's like hanging out with his
girlfriend he's like listen honey i'm
telling you that
you're gonna go vote for joe biden and
then she goes yes
through international cooperation under
pressure
zachary cuny says tim ian was right
about using viruses to insert genes into
cells
yes i learned that from andreas i i i
know that's true i'm saying they don't
use coronaviruses to do it well that we
know
i'm a chemistry phd student with a focus
on biophysics and i'd love to talk with
you guys about that and the crisper
babies sometimes
oh crisper af says forget the hundred
million
tim when were your album dropped you see
let me let me tell you something
i don't know if i you know i'm gonna
avoid that story because it's it's
personal to a high profile individual
but i'll just say this
at a certain point you can't buy
anything you can't buy you can't you
stop being able to buy things
i love let's say let's say you're uh uh
you want to get from new york to la for
an important meeting
what's the fastest way to do it uber
airplane yeah you go to the you go you
buy
you get a first class ticket i guess
you're comfortable as you're going
through all the airport bs
you can't i guess at a certain point if
you're really wealthy
you can buy security bypass where you
can like
take a car into the airport to go
through security if you have a private
plane still going to an airport
still have to go to the airport stuff
get an appliance off the fly i guess if
you're wealthy enough a private plane
is it's easier i guess you gotta worry
about security and faster but for the
most part
it's just easier to book a ticket and
it's like hard to chart a private plane
sometimes unless you own it then you're
super rich i guess
but at a certain point you there's you
could only do what humans can do
you can't go you can't go to mars you
can't buy money's not gonna get you
there elon's trying
but he's he's paving the way he's the
one who's who's you know he's he's he's
making that path but it's not the money
it's the technical right
to the israeli professor there are
humans
in mars you can't buy your way there i
don't know
why wouldn't elon musk just you know
just throw money into space maybe
but the question about the album in my
opinion i know how you feel about this
but i feel like the
the age of albums is over now it's just
singles
right exactly so uh the issue is the
reason i bring up the money thing is
recording the music is a matter of
willpower i have to prioritize
and so i want to we want to launch this
vlog
and we're working towards that direction
there's a lot of things we have to do
before that
administrative level and recording music
is like third burner for me you should
record
the for the vlog record the recording
process yeah we could totally do that
that's that's the way to do it right
and then you can hear like the isolated
vocal tracks and you can be like wow
tim's terrible at singing
really good you were great on the last
one well what people don't realize too
is if you've ever actually listened to
isolated vocal tracks with no effects
you realize that most singers for most
music are like
decent it's rough yeah yeah it's it's
fairly rough it's all auto-tuned
yeah no no not auto-tune like so the
stuff i did was not auto tune at all
it's like and and uh i can't remember
who said it but they're like you can
tell tim does like a vibrato but
i'm by no means like a great singer i
can just sing
and so what happens though is there's
like reverb added to it
not to make me sing better but to mix it
with the other instruments and stuff
like that
singing in the garage it's the acoustics
are incredible in there oh yeah i heard
you
i thought i heard a dying cat oh it was
quite well i was like shaking off the
days of what
i was trying to take a nap right i kept
thinking about you
lone star cooking show says anyone in
the studio do your best impress
impression of trump telling the nation
aliens exist example i know the best
aliens nobody knows more aliens than me
the radical left aliens are trying to
bring
socialism dc says hey tim
have you considered making a discord
server i will not make a discord server
um because it gets rated immediately by
psychopaths who post
psychotic things and then the left will
go in
write a bunch of crazy stuff screenshot
it and then post it saying it with
somebody else
yep easiest thing in the world no i'm
not interested in that
yeah i i was quoting a news story from
vox
that was making a racist argument and
then it was screenshot out of context
and then leftist tried using it to get
me banned could be do something we could
do with like
uh people that pay like a monthly part
of the subscribe monthly we can have
access to a server or something
we are setting up a members only server
so everybody who's you know signed up
will have access to exclusive content
live streams that's gonna be part of the
vlog stuff we're doing so we're gonna
start doing too is like at the end of
shows
a bonus segment that will go up on the
website exclusive remembers
the reason for it is i've actually been
really bad at monetizing
um compared to a lot of other people so
there are people with
way like so i'll put it this way a
subscriber a paying subscriber
is worth money a youtube subscriber is
someone who just follows you
so if if you know so i've got like um
millions of followers
if they were all giving a dollar or two
dollars a month or five dollars a month
then i'd have that hundred million
dollars a year you know i'm it's a
ridiculous amount of money
then i could build and do whatever i
want instead i've been relying on
you know super chats which are good but
kind of random we don't know
what it's going to come out to ad
revenue is random it goes up and down
january is going to be
miserable for everybody because added
rates just tank especially the
election's over so viewership's going
down ad rates are going oh because end
of year budget people just dump their
advertising budget december goes crazy
but then january there is no budget so
no one's spending
i just sell shirts but so so i'm
thinking about like
um instead of just kind of mass
producing tons and tons of content we
should probably do
tons of content but an actual base
you know i'll put it this way you're
actually better off
having a hundred thousand hardcore fans
who love you and not being all that
famous and and then getting like 50 000
to pay five bucks a month because then
you're super rich
you don't have to worry about getting
cancelled for the most part you have
millions of followers you're relying on
ad revenue you can make a lot of money
but then you're a huge target yeah
because you have you know so it's like
we got to figure out
so you know i pull back a little bit i'm
producing three less seconds per day
we're moving we're doing more segments
on this show which you probably noticed
we broke things up into segments
uh this this time around to actually i
think it's it's it's it's
more formulaic we've been um
investigating getting a giant laser and
cnc machine to produce like um
stuff that we can sell like cups with
like tim cast etched into them and
things so if you guys are interested in
that kind of thing
well so tweet me about that this is kind
of the balance i'm like you know at a
certain point you can only grow so much
but we want to create a better
place for people to hang out and have
fun i mean just like
luke was walking around in a ghillie
suit the other day because he's because
he's ridiculous
testing it out next to the christmas
theory right it was serious
logistics he stood next to the christmas
tree he could yes he could
iron you ron paul started he looked like
a wookiee
but uh uh also i don't i don't know if i
should i mentioned who came over to hang
out the other day you should
yeah he posted it he posted it on
instagram oh that's right james okay oh
that's right the photos
james o'keefe was hanging out yeah and
he was djing yeah i don't know i don't
know
that was strange i was like are you
kidding are you pranking me man and then
he like you're literally
creating them we should have filmed it
yes because then we could have been
so much fun like james o'keefe for some
reason cameron has started djing for us
and he you know what he did am i am i
giving away secrets if i tell people
i don't think so okay i'm saying i'm
telling i'm saying sorry james i'm
telling everyone your secret
he played his retracto song the
correction alpaca
mixed with billie jean um
and i'm like i'm sitting there we were
watching the santa claus too all right
while james o'keefe was djing and we had
ordered uh uh
money can't buy this kind of quality i
know yeah i know that was fantastic
i'm like it's like probably film this
because it's weird
but when we have people come like when
we have guests like we hang out for kind
of kind of a bit there's like we're
playing skee-ball
game so yeah james was like when's
when's the next time we're all going to
be hanging out i'm like in the fema
camps yeah
oh yeah yeah probably v
mole one says bob loblaw's law blog lobs
law bombs oh my
arrested development bob loblaw's law
blog
i also like and uh uh 30 rock um
was it the rural juror and then she's
like the movie she's in is called the
rural juror but she keeps saying the
rural juror
and they're like the roger the rural
juror
and then she and then the sequel is
urban fervor
they can't figure out what they're
saying i love it crimson id says the ap
has called the existence of aliens and
astronomical impossibility
are they going to put a fact check on
this video yeah they're like there are
no aliens
don't look down the curtain brewmaster
monk says we need things to take actual
effort with real trade-offs so that our
activities and skills represent our
personal values
it's a sexual selection thing else we
would fall into existential despair
yeah we all had everything access to
everything existential despair maybe but
then maybe we'll get past it who knows
no i don't think video games get boring
when you could do anything and
everything
tj rainman says tim i'm missing the
segments on the on the day today
with my limited amount of time to look
for news i really value multiple videos
each day
but what we're doing is taking segments
from this show in the 6 p.m slot now
so i'm on my on my other channels i'm
doing i'm no longer doing 6
6 15 and 6 30 which were the short 10
minute segments because that
really like it takes those are three
stories they're shorter but it's a lot
more yeah but it's research
so like each story requires a certain
amount of research to where it's like
tracking down stories comparing them
kind of fact-checking a little bit
and then doing three doing six these
these last three
are shorter and don't you know it's just
i don't know
it was a it was the biggest burden to
like reduce to do
to do the vlog and i just think we got
to build culture like having that video
where you
like if we had a video where you could
see james o'keefe djing the song
it would be humanizing in a lot of ways
that people don't understand about james
they like these leftists have this view
of him like he's some evil mustache
twirling villain or something
you just see him hanging out like eating
or when you're playing basketball
oh yeah yeah and luke did a bank shot
off the six foot mini ramp and got it
into the hoop on your instagram
video got seventy thousand views on
instagram that's what i'm talking about
more pointless stuff like that it's not
that it's pointless i'm joking i'm
joking
the idea is are we connecting with the
younger generation by talking about
top-level politics and stuff sometimes
sometimes probably not it's not about
losing people it's about inspiring
younger people to to
like we want people to understand and
agree with us
well we've gotta we gotta approach them
in a bunch of different ways we can't
just
keep talking about esoteric political
issues and think they're going to know
or care
yeah you can't berate them you got to
have fun doing what you're doing and you
got to show people
that side of it and i really think
there's a place that millennials and gen
z really need
friends i think that if you can kind of
step into that and kind of be their
friend they need
role models because they have very poor
role models
everywhere out there you look at every
tv show how they highlight and and focus
on a man
oh it is bad let's see jacob diaz says
the left isn't
all that opposed to the concept of
borders they would just have them
situated in a way that a
way that a way they obstruct the
individual above all else
jeffrey perrine says please consider
letting me on your show i think i can
prove the bible
the flood giant's new world order the
mark two thousand year old text that has
info that at least needs to be disclosed
i mean it's actually pretty interesting
um yes i would listen to it
yeah yeah i was thinking about having
like a pastor or somebody yeah do you
want to write down
jeffrey perrine or actually should we
have him uh do do we have the
the public email yeah it's been the ufo
spin the ufo
in a while email spin the ufo gmail.com
i will check it for you ralph misk says
check luke but it's like c-z-e-c
hey tim 1983 is a polio take
orwell's 1984 on netflix okay
uh alice beal says hey tim what if
aliens also believe in god like
if there's an alien jesus which is why
they are peaceful and don't like human
violence
maybe or what if they have like what if
what if they actually have their own
kind of like alien jesus and he's called
like
alien you know juan alien juan yeah
and then they come here and they're like
clearly one is the one true prophet of
god
the one and then we're like no it's not
and then all that
what if like what if it's a very similar
religion like no think about it like
you know we have all these shared myth
like uh
mythos around worshiping the stars a
bunch of different cultures
what if aliens came and had the same
things i bet they will that'd be crazy
worshiping like they have a god and they
have you know allegories
the story of christmas repeats
culturally through many civilizations
yeah logan foster says
watch the phenomenon it's a documentary
about ufos a recent podcast from joe
rogan with james fox and
jacques val valley talked about it also
watch the tom de long podcast with joe
rogan interesting yeah
it's too bad i think they've been
removed from youtube tom delong is one
of the key people fighting for
uh revealing information about ufos he
would be great
to talk to him yeah that'd be cool i i i
when i was i was a big fan of blink with
two when i was a little kid
i love playing we if you're listening
or if someone knows tom big fan you
should come on the show talk about
aliens absolutely let's play some music
while you're here
brewmaster monk oh definitely yeah we'll
jam too that'd be a fun vlog brewmaster
monk says what happens
to a world that is dependent on matrix
level tech and tech and the tech
breaks are you willing to make a baby
with someone who's only adapted to
pushing buttons
if she's hot that's that's the crazy
that's the crazy thing like i gotta get
to know her first
no but like you gotta know how to
survive a zombie apocalypse man and i
can't be carrying you when the zombies
are coming right
if if we're so dependent on technology
what's going to happen if there's a
solar flare
and everyone has microchips in there
sticks and stones i got
a faraday cage with a microwave inside
of it and a computer inside the
microwave so i'm good
see in the land of the technologically
addicted
and a solar flare the man with the
faraday cage cell phone is king
or with just skills that he learns how
to be in the wild by himself
books yes i'll tell you what you learn
your survival skills nope
i'll take my cell phone with solar
charger crank charger backups
in my faraday double faraday cage and
then when you're like
listen i know how to catch a chicken i'm
gonna be like i can tell you how to make
gunpowder i will make you the chicken
and then i will make you the apocalyptic
world
i'll be like alex jones looking looking
at you like you're my neighbor
listen listen gosh if the apocalypse
happened and all technology got burned
out
and one person had a cell phone that was
like had a bunch of
imagine imagine it didn't even have
anything downloaded on it it just had
like stored in the ram like some
wikipedia files
that person would be like the most
valuable and you could probably grow
that person probably wouldn't tell
anyone that they had it because someone
would try and take it so did that
actually happen in history
like you think about the cover-up of
atlantis it was lost so if these people
really had the secrets of like
agriculture they wouldn't have told us i
have a good idea for a short film
it's like a bunch of like kind of
primitive people and they're tracking
down
like the tree of knowledge the you know
it's a magical device that's said to
to grant you the ability to to
understand the world
and so they're having this big battle
and finally they like make their way to
the to the enemy fortress they break in
there's a war and people are dying
one guy finally makes it through kicks
the door in and then there it is
it's an iphone and then you and then
like it zooms out and it's it's actually
the world they're in is like two
thousand years after the fall of
civilization
and the iphone is still survives and
it's all like selfies and
no no private pictures no like it's been
like it's like horribly maintained by
a really old guy and there's like a
solar charger on it and they're reading
through like ancient knowledge and stuff
lol text message i was thinking about
where the main character is the cell
phone and it just follows
like people get killed and the phone
drops and someone else picks it up and
it like the movie follows
and then and then at the end it turns
out the phone was the villain the whole
time
yeah oh man all right let's see there is
a high likelihood the phone will have
like 200 selfies of a girl in there
yeah no doubt all of them do ken rick
kenrick grunwald says have you
have you ever heard of the missing 400
the 411 411
or the trend of people mysteriously
going missing in national parks
aliens tito latino says fent sitter keep
with the good work
voting in basketball arenas made for an
irregular and interesting influence plus
amazing aliens christmas story
the star from the twilight zone
brewmaster monk says the aliens are a
lie
you can tell because it's an israeli and
they're tr i'm not gonna read that
that was mean yeah no no no
uh v ben says the entire joe rogan
experience is on the pirate bay
paul viter says hey tim what if the
aliens are the angels who were kicked
out of heaven
and they mean to bring about end times
as in revelations keep culture alive
that's what i was talking about
religious people believing that aliens
are actually fallen demons
or angels yes no that's what people
believe
i'm not saying it's true i'm just saying
there's three kind of belief systems
what is it
what if the bible was just propaganda
yeah
it seems like it is propaganda like a
history book it seems like probably
institutional power is trying to make
sure people don't believe in it
god god won and and casts is satan down
to earth or whatever or to hell or
whatever
see history is written by the winners
yeah good point i think the angels
took a bunch of like i think adam or no
no not adam michael was one of the
archangels and that these dudes
used to take a bunch of psychedelics and
sit and group and meditate and they
started to have these group meditations
where they'd be like god is speaking to
us and they'd be like
yes we're all hearing it we're all
seeing it but the voice would come
through michael and he would be like i'm
speaking
god and then they became like this cult
and then lucifer was like these guys are
out of their minds let me talk to the
plebes and give them the power of all
this
and they were like no he's a bad guy
lucifer stopped and then they created
a war and there's all this there are
libraries out there that religion was
brought by
a lot of mushrooms so that's a theory
with that being said we've now gone from
aliens exist
there's military weapons wiping
everybody out and then joe rogan's
leaving youtube
and then finally people are taking
mushrooms yes and creating a religion
thanks for hanging out everybody make
sure to follow me on twitter instagram
parlor at tim catching check out my
other channels youtube.comtimcastnews
and youtube.comtimcast subscribe hit the
like button hit the notification about
we are live monday to friday at 8pm
you can find us on itunes and spotify
and if you haven't already you know
seriously
go check us out there and subscribe
because if you missed the show you can
watch it there
but we also do put up clips throughout
the day um the day after the show so you
actually get you know clips from the
show
on each individual segments which a lot
of people tend to watch more than the
show
but uh luke thanks for hanging out you
can follow luke of course i am still
uh you know kidnapped here for now we'll
see what happens
you can find my work on youtube.com
forward slash we
are change we are change on youtube look
we are change on twitter and instagram
right on some other people in the room i
guess oh holler
follow me all over the internet at ian
crossland and hey luke before we go tell
me a little bit about your merchandise
and where i can buy
you are too nice to meet teesprings.com
forward slash we are change and you can
get shirts like the one i'm wearing
right now that says make or well fiction
again
i love it there you go and of course you
can work you can follow at sour patch
lids
you can you can follow me sour patch
lids lyds on twitter if you want to i
don't know why you would want to but i
am there i want to
we are back tomorrow the day of the safe
harbor deadline to discuss
what is happening with donald trump's
legal challenge to become president
tomorrow's gonna be one of the most
important days because if the challenges
aren't resolved it could theoretically
put electoral college votes
into purgatory and then joe biden
doesn't win so we'll see how it plays
out make sure you tune in for that
and we will see you all tomorrow bye
guys
you